aujourd'hui 2 éditions sont programmées
celles de Madame Corinne Lepage puis
celle du directeur général de landra
donc agence nationale pour la gestion
des déchets radioactifs je précise que
cette programmation a un caractère
fortuit aux agenda des personnes
entendues et pas forcément de logique
successives alors pour Madame Lepage
donc madame la ministre
nous vous remercions d'avoir répondu
presque intentantément à notre
invitation notre commission d'enquête
aborde avec votre audition un cycle au
cours duquel seront entendus diverses
personnalités du monde politique et
c'est sans raison donc des
responsabilités ministérielles que vous
avez exercées de 1995 à 1997 au sein du
gouvernement alors dirigé par Alain
Juppé que nous avons souhaité vous
recevoir
cette période a été marquée notamment
par le redémarrage puis l'arrêt
définitif de super Phénix acté en 1998
donc après votre départ du gouvernement
12 ans à peine après sa mise en service
ce réacteur destiné à produire autant ou
plus de matériaux difficiles qui n'en
consomme avait suscité de vivre
oppositions cette période a aussi été
dans le domaine l'environnement
caractérisé par des évolutions
importantes en particulier une loi qui a
pris votre nom sur la pollution de l'air
qui a dessiné le cadre dans lequel
seront pris en compte d'abord les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre puis
le changement climatique avec trois
motor dans la concertation avec les
associations le droit à l'information et
la planification
mais votre audition est également
l'occasion pour la commission d'enquête
de recueillir diverses informations non
directement liées à vos fonctions
ministérielles passées d'une part vous
incarnez un courant de pensée celui du
réformisme écologique ou de l'écologie
soutenable d'autre part vos activités
professionnelles d'avocats ont témoigné
à la fois de votre
engagement mais aussi de l'attention
médiatique que vous avez suscité sur un
certain nombre de dossiers enfin vous
avez été député européenne de 2009 à
2014 lors de l'émergence de la
problématique sur le changement
climatique de la définition des
premières orientations concernant le mix
énergétique
à l'époque 20% d'énergie renouvelables
dans la consommation finale en 2020 mais
aussi de la libéralisation régulier des
marchés de l'énergie
quelques sources
indiquent que vous avez également plaidé
pour les énergies marines lesquels ne se
limitent pas à l'éolien offshore voilà
après cette courte introduction et
contextualisation je vous laisse madame
la ministre la parole pour un exposé
d'une dizaine quinzaine de minutes avant
que nous centrions dans un échange plus
itératif mais auparavant et en
application de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires il me revient
de vous demander de bien vouloir prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité en
conséquence de quoi je vous demande de
bien vouloir lever la main droite et de
dire je jure
c'est bien noté mais écoutez je vous
laisse la parole
faut simplement allumer le micro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames messieurs d'abord je vous
remercie de m'avoir demandé d'intervenir
et c'est vrai que j'ai accepté dans la
foulée de la réception du document que
vous m'avez adressé je me suis donc
efforcée de préparer les réponses aux
questions que vous avez bien voulu me
poser et avant cela si vous l'acceptez
je voudrais dire quelques mots à titre
préliminaire
lorsqu Alain Juppé Jacques Chirac mon
fait l'honneur de me proposer d'être
ministre de l'Environnement c'était en
raison de mes engagements
environnementaux l'amour cocaïs mais pas
que puisque
était de notoriété publique que j'avais
défendu de très nombreuses collectivités
à l'époque c'était beaucoup de
collectivités locales d'ailleurs je note
du reste des points communs avec ceux
qui aujourd'hui veulent pas d'éolienne
c'est un peu la même chose beaucoup de
mais sauf qu'une centrale nucléaire
c'est pas une éolienne beaucoup de
communes qui ne voulaient pas de
centrales nucléaires chez elle donc je
veux dire que les choses étaient sur la
table dès mon entrée au gouvernement
j'ai évidemment quitté le barreau ça
c'est la loi
mais de surcroît et ça c'est pas la loi
tout au moins c'était pas obligatoire en
1995 tous les dossiers d'environnement
qui étaient à mon cabinet enfin mon
précédent cabinet puisque je n'étais
plus avocate ont quitté ce cabinet pour
aller sur un autre cabinet et ce sous le
contrôle du bâtonnet Lafarge qui était
le bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats la
cour d'appel de Paris donc les choses
ont été réglées de manière extrêmement
claire j'ajoute de manière à ce que le
sujet soit totalement éclusé
que sans que personne ne donne de rien
du tout et sans qu'aucune disposition
législative ne m'impose quoi que ce soit
je me suis imposée à moi-même un délai
de viduité de 10 ans
avant de retoucher un dossier nucléaire
le premier dossier nucléaire que j'ai
repris c'est en 2007 je rappelle
simplement que pour la Haute Autorité de
la vie politique c'est 3 ans 5 ans quand
c'est très rigoureux moi je me suis
imposé 10 ans alors aujourd'hui quand je
vois de si de là des allusions au fait
que j'aurais eu un conflit d'intérêt
j'aimerais beaucoup que dans la France
il y ait autant de conflits d'intérêt
que je m'ennuie moi-même
troisième point durant toutes les
exercices de mes fonctions
j'estime avoir été d'une parfaite
loyauté à l'égard du gouvernement auquel
j'avais l'honneur d'appartenir et en
particulier
tout en défendant le domaine de
compétences qui m'était confiée ce qui
est imposait que je défends
l'environnement bien sûr j'étais là pour
ça je veux souligner ici que lors de la
reprise des essais nucléaires qui
n'était pas forcément mon choix comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer non seulement je
n'ai pris aucune position publique mais
tant en cause ce choix dont j'estimais
qu'il avait été fait par le Président de
la République
ortho transparence avant que je n'en
trouvement mais par-dessus le marché
j'ai défendu la position française à
Bruxelles et c'était pas forcément
facile et avec un certain succès voilà
je voulais préciser ces points avant de
répondre aux différents points que
différentes questions que vous avez bien
voulu me poser mais je voulais que les
choses soient claires et net parce que
dans mon esprit elle le sent
alors à titre préliminaire
sur la première question que vous posez
sur la citation actuelle
j'observe que indépendamment de la
question de l'électricité nous avons
près de 60% notre énergie qui vient du
pétrole et du gaz dont nous sommes
forcément dépendants puisqu'on n'a pas
chez nous on a eu un peu de gaz à lac
c'est de l'histoire ancienne un peu de
pétrole à part entière une histoire très
très ancienne et donc nous dépendons sur
le plan de ce qui n'est pas
l'électricité totalement du reste du
monde
quand un autre électricité effectivement
elle est largement d'origine nucléaire
ce que dans la comptabilité française on
estime être une source d'indépendance
j'insiste j'insiste simplement sur le
fait que dans d'autres pays ce n'est pas
la position qui a été adoptée puisque
dans d'autres pays l'origine
l'électricité nucléaire est considérée
comme une électricité d'assurant pas
l'indépendance tout simplement parce
qu'il y a pas d'uranium sur le
territoire des pays qui font de
l'électricité nucléaire
de surcroît notre consommation
énergétique reste beaucoup trop
importante je renvoie cet égard au
rapport de l'argent c'est internationale
de l'énergie de novembre 2021 tout les
documents que je cite messieurs sont
dans une cote que je vous remettrai donc
vous n'aurez pas et si vous voulez une
version numérique je pourrais évidemment
vous l'envoyer si vous le souhaitez donc
vous n'aurez pas à chercher quoi que ce
soit j'ai tout sorti notre consommation
énergétique est beaucoup trop important
de voir le rapport de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie de novembre
21 nous étions à l'époque à 141 millions
de tonnes équivalent pétrole alors que
nous aurions dû être à 130 millions donc
il y a un excès qui est considérable ça
c'est toute la partie qui n'est pas
électrique
sur la question électrique
je dirais que j'ai le sentiment d'un
immense gâchis
[Musique]
et le problème de la transparence et du
contrôle qui était nettement amélioré en
2007 mais ce dont je vous parle c'est
1979-1980 enfin c'est cette année-là qui
sont des années anciennes
pourquoi un immense gâchis je me permets
de citer et vous le trouverez également
là-dedans un rapport qui est très
intéressant de l'OPEX nous sommes dans
ces locaux donc c'est hommage lui est
rendu
un peu ancien il est vrai de février 99
de vous
prédécesseurs notables si je puis dire
mais sur Robert Gallet que je viens
connu par ailleurs que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié et Christian Bataille
cet extrait que vous trouverez est très
intéressant il est question de quoi il
est question de qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
la rampe nucléaire ça c'est une question
qu'on se posait à la fin des années 90
et si j'ai sorti ce document c'est parce
que il est très intéressant sur ce point
que dit le que dit le rapport il dit
voilà il y a plusieurs choix qui sont
possibles on peut donner de l'argent aux
Français en
abaissant encore le prix de
l'électricité
on peut investir et je reviendrai sur
l'affaire de l'EPR que j'ai ça pourra
vous étonner défendu
en 1996 lorsque j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller à la Hague avec Madame Angela
Merkel qui était mon homologue de
l'époque des ministres de
l'Environnement en Allemagne et avec le
ministre de l'Industrie monsieur brotra
pour présenter le Pr parce que à
l'époque c'est ce qui apparaissait comme
étant la suite logique du programme du
programme français donc on dit bah
écoutez voilà on peut faire cet
investissement là et puis on peut
investir dans l'entretien de des
centrales existantes mais ce que dit ce
rapport c'est surtout ne privatisez pas
ça date de 99 or qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on a fait tout le contraire et en fait à
mon sens mais c'est mon point de vue
vous me le demandez donc je me permets
de l'exprimer
les choix qui ont été faits
d'investissement massifs à l'étranger ce
sont révélés des choix absolument
catastrophiques
catastrophique d'abord parce que ça
débouché sur pas grand chose je pense à
poster lation aux États-Unis 5 milliards
quand même
l'achat de British énergy 14 milliards
ça va laisser tout 8 plus les
investissements fait en Amérique du Sud
donc en fait la rampe nucléaire monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Rapporteur elle
est partie largement dans ses
investissements qui ne nous ont servi à
vraiment pas grand chose
deuxièmement une politique des prix qui
est en réalité qui s'est révélée très
contre-productive en effet nous sommes
partis avec une surcapacité
je ne reviendrai pas sur l'historique
vous le connaissez aussi bien que moi
mais je peux vous dire qu'en tant
qu'avocate quand je plaidais à la fin
des années 80 notamment pour la centrale
de 4 non je me souviens de ça
je plaidais sur le fait qu'il y avait
tout ce qu'il fallait qu'on n'avait pas
besoin de centrale en plus les documents
qui étaient fournis à l'époque par EDF
étaient des trendes qui partaient de
1960 et qui était comme ça sauf que
entre 1960 et 1900 on était en 89 donc
on avait les chiffres de 1980 par
définition donc ils avaient rien à voir
avec la présentation qui était faite il
y a eu 73 et 73 il y avait eu une chute
de la consommation considérable grâce à
une vraie politique de maîtrise de
l'énergie pour une fois si je puis dire
et donc les chiffres étaient faux donc
on savait pertinemment qu'on était en
surcapacité
et tantôt sur capacité et avec une
incapacité de stockage de l'électricité
puisqu'à l'époque on parlait pas de
batterie il fallait bien consommer cette
électricité donc le choix financier qui
a été fait par EDF à l'époque avec la
cour de l'Etat fait par EDF consistait à
avoir une politique de prix très bas
pour consommer toute cette électricité
et donc encourager la consommation
électrique et c'est comme ça que la
France s'est dotée du chauffage
électrique à gogo
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
lorsqu'il y a et c'est vrai encore
aujourd'hui se fait partie de nos
difficultés une pointe de consommation
liée au froid
50% de la pointe européenne et française
ça c'est la suite de cette politique qui
a été mise en place donc avec cet
encouragement au chauffage électrique et
la situation dans laquelle se retrouve
les ménages français aujourd'hui
effectivement confrontés à une
augmentation du prix de l'électricité
même si le gouvernement fait à juste
titre ce qu'il peut pour essayer de
limiter la hausse des coûts mais voilà
c'est un choix politique et économique
au financier qui a été fait dans les
années 1980
troisièmement une perte de compétences
tout le monde est d'accord là-dessus
mais je suis quand même un peu étonné
de constater que personne ne parle de la
sous-traitance
or une partie de cette perte de
compétence est liée au fait que
progressivement pour des raisons
économiques pour des raisons de droit du
travail
de nombreuses tâches qui au départ
étaient des tâches subalterne mais qui
sont devenus de moins en moins
subalterne ont été confiées à des
entreprises de sous-traitance qui
n'avaient évidemment pas la compétence
pour le faire mais qui coûtait pas cher
et dont le personnel n'était pas
surveillé de la même manière que l'été
le E personnel de DF et je pense que
ceci a participé aussi de la situation
dans laquelle nous nous sommes trouvés
ensuite on a misé sur le Pr je disais
tout à l'heure que j'ai participé à
cette situation puisque j'ai été vantée
en 1996 les mérites de l'EPA puisqu'à
l'époque c'était présenté comme étant la
suite logique de ce qu'on faisait sauf
que
le Pr en réalité le fiasco en face
duquel nous nous trouvons il trouve
toute une série de causes et je me
permets à cet égard de renvoyer au
rapport de la Cour des comptes que vous
trouverez également là-dedans sur le
sujet de l'EPR qui est extrêmement bien
fait comme tous les rapports de la Cour
des comptes qui rappelle qu'au départ
la difficulté est venue d'une bagarre
Areva
EDF
avec le lancement dans des conditions
acrobatiques de
l'EPR finlandais à des coûts défiant
toute concurrence et dans des délais
défiant toute concurrence et donc ce que
dit la Cour des comptes c'est que tout
ça est parti sur des références
techniques
erronées sur des études détaillées
insuffisantes sur
une estimation initiale irréaliste sur
un défaut d'organisation du suivi
sur des contrats qui ont connu des
augmentations
ubuesque entre 100 et 700 % dit la Cour
des comptes sur un défaut de contrôle
sur un retard dans la reconnaissance des
défauts de compétences et sur le refus
def d'informer en temps et en heure
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire des
règles d'exclusion de rupture qui
n'étaient pas respectées et ça c'était
connu depuis 2013 et l'information a été
donnée en 2017 donc tous ces documents
je ne les éléments je les inventent pas
c'est le rapport de la Cour des comptes
et
ce fait d'avoir tout misé sur le père à
entraîné corrélativement un défaut
d'intérêt sur le parc existant et donc
de perte de cette compétence dont
plaignons aujourd'hui sur la possibilité
de savoir construire encore il faut
comprendre que à la fin des années 90 on
avait trop d'électricité ça m'est plus
quoi en faire quelque part et donc le
problème d'en faire d'autres franchement
n'était pas un problème à l'ordre du
jour
et pourtant le rap de Lopez que auquel
je fais allusion que vous trouverez
montre très bien la situation
d'aujourd'hui c'était prévu c'était
parfaitement connu à la fin des années
90 pas raconter de blague
avec l'idée à l'époque que les réacteurs
ne pourraient tenir que 30 ans voire 40
on est aujourd'hui à 50 voire 60
ensuite
donc ça c'est la première partie de
l'état de la situation actuelle
le deuxième point à mon sens
c'est le refus de lancer une véritable
politique en faveur des énergies
renouvelables
l'opposition est l'éolien elle est
ancienne elle date de 2005 2006
je rappelle qu'en 2010
le gouvernement a décidé de sacrifier
purement et simplement la filière
solaire française
du fait du moratoire si 10 000 emplois
qui ont été perdus sans que ça n'euve
visiblement personne
toutes les boîtes enfermées
et les entreprises sont partis
s'installer en Europe ailleurs mais pas
en France
je ne veux pas être trop longue vous
m'avez dit 10 minutes monsieur le
Président et
donc je veux pas être trop longue mais
je me suis permis quand même de vous
mettre dans le les références mais je
pense que vous les connaissez les
chiffres auxquels nous sommes nous en
matière d'énergie renouvelable et les
chiffres auxquels sont nos voisins on
dit franchement pas bon on est les seuls
en Europe à n'avoir pas atteint nos
objectifs en 2020 avec 19% de beta 23%
et un objectif qui est à 40% 2030 qui à
mon sens est inatteignable et c'est pas
avec la loi que j'espère vous allez
voter tout à l'heure qu'on va y arriver
faut pas rêver c'est absolument
impossible donc on a retard absolument
colossal et je dois dire puisque je suis
devant la représentation nationale que
j'ai été particulièrement choquée de
voir des campagnes de presse
au cours du week-end je ne sais pas ce
que ça coûte mais ça coûte très cher des
pages entières dans le Figaro dans le
monde dans Les Echos deux pages entières
pour dire que non non pas du tout il n'y
a pas de retard en matière d'énergie
renouvelable et en fait on en a pas
besoin du tout c'est une absurdité vous
prenez tous les rapports que ce soit RTE
que ce soit dame que ce soit qui vous
voulez même qui prévoit du nucléaire à
l'horizon 2050 ils insistent tous
sur la nécessité absolue de développer
massivement notre renouvelable par votre
conséquence on a un vrai problème
et
je donne un autre exemple en 2022 il y a
eu une augmentation de 47 % du
photovoltaïque en Europe vous rendez
compte 47 % d'augmentation en un an en
France on a réalisé
2,7 gigawatts
ce qui est vraiment vraiment très très
peu et c'est 50 GW qui sont atteints au
niveau européen en 2023 et vous avez des
pays comme la Suède qui sont aujourd'hui
à 60% d'énergie renouvelables donc quand
on dit c'est accessoire marginal ça sert
à rien etc mais c'est pas vrai c'est du
déni pur et simple je terminerai sur ce
bilan sur vraiment ma tristesse devant
l'abandon quasi systématique des
solutions nouvelles lorsqu'elles se
présente je vais vous donner trois
exemples premier exemple biogaz la
méthanisation
l'agriculture allemande s'est mis à la
méthanisation dans les années 2008-2009
ça a permis un revenu accessoire pour le
monde agricole extrêmement important qui
a permis à l'Allemagne de passer devant
notre agriculture quasiment à la fin des
années 2010
les méthanisations chez nous elle est
débutante
je me souviens avoir visité en Vendée en
2012 la première peut-être installation
de méthanisation le pauvre type qui
avait mis ça en route il avait mis 8 ans
installé
ces quatre
fours de méthanisation premier exemple
deuxième exemple le solaire indépendant
expérience de solaire directe créée en
2007 ou 2008
racheté par engie disparaît de la
circulation
et nous n'avons pas malgré les efforts
qui ont été faits par les CEA parce que
le CEA a nourri en son sein des tas de
pépites sur le solaire grâce à un homme
formidable s'appelle Jean terme qui
menait ce secteur au CEA
on a eu aucune grande entreprise dans le
domaine du soleil troisième exemple la
méthanation ou le power to gaz qui
consiste vous le savez mais je me
permets de lui rappeler à stocker
de l'électricité renouvelable pour en
faire pour l'utiliser pour de
l'électrolyse fabriquer de l'hydrogène
la mélanger avec du CO2 et sa fabrique
un méthane artificiel en quelque sorte
un méthane propre ça s'appelle la
méthanation c'est une technologie qui a
été développée en Allemagne au milieu
des années 2000
lorsqu'il y a eu le grand débat en 2007
ou 2008 en France sur l'énergie je
m'étais permis de produire dans la
commission qui s'est occupée du sujet un
document sur le power to gaz qui peut
être power to gas to power d'ailleurs
parce qu'on peut ensuite fabriquer
d'électricité et bien il a fallu
attendre 2018 ou 2019 pour qu'on ait le
premier prototype à Marseille alors que
nous avons une technologie remarquable
une capacité de stockage qui est 300
fois
plus importante que celle de
l'électricité
et que
d'ici
2030 on pense que la technologie sera
opérationnelle permettant de stocker de
20 à 30 terwatt heures par an de
fabriquer de 30 à 20 à 30 terwatts par
an de gaz vert voilà ces trois exemples
qui en tant que citoyennes si vous
voulez parce que j'ai plus aucune
fonction m'ont fait mal au cœur parce
que c'est des choses qu'on savait faire
on avait l'industrie française pour le
faire on l'a pas fait au total sur ce
premier point on constate un
surdimensionnement
qui a annulé toute politique de baisse
de la consommation et d'investissement
une perte d'autofinancement de DF est la
disparition de toute espoir
d'exportation de pr moi je veux bien
qu'au continuer à dire qu'on va en
vendre mais personne ne nous achète une
installation qui marche dans les
conditions que l'on connaît
l'opposition à la massification du
renouvelable et enfin une difficulté
avec l'Union européenne aujourd'hui
parce que la situation française
déséquilibre en fait tout le marché
européen
et le plus grave à mon sens c'est qu'on
ne tire aucune leçon de tout ce qui nous
est arrivé
quand vous relierez je vous ai mis dans
le dossier
ce qui était écrit à propos de
superhénix par la Cour des comptes en
1997 en disant qu'on avait surestimé
notre capacité de faire on a on continue
sur la même lancée
les centrales nucléaires sur lesquels on
a des problèmes aujourd'hui
ce sont pas les 900 MW qu'on a construit
sur la filière Westinghouse de 1973
non pas du tout c'est les autres c'est
ceux qui font 1200 mow 1000 MW
1300 MW parce que là aussi les
ingénieurs de développement
reconnaissent on a fait des histoires de
courbe de coude de je ne sais quoi qui
fait que aujourd'hui on est en face des
difficultés que l'on connaît et
Smallville ça a été exactement le même
problème j'aurais un point spécial bien
sûr sur Chris ma vie puisque me poser
des questions et donc j'ai le sentiment
qu'on continue
on continue je vous ai mis dans le
dossier un truc tout récent tout bête
mais quand même
pour le père de flamantsville on a
besoin
de refaire des un certain nombre de
tuyaux je sais pas quel terme exact je
ne suis pas ingénieur je ne sais que on
sait plus les faire chez nous on envoie
ça en Italie
très bien sauf que l'ASN a été se
promener en Italie et a été scandalisé
de la manière dont elle a vu que ce
fabriqué ces instruments qui serviront
ensuite à Flamanville
est-ce que c'est bien sérieux je veux
dire quels sont les leçons que l'on tire
de du passé
j'ajouterai enfin et c'est important me
semble-t-il sur la question de la
dépendance le fait que tout ceci
et en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
n'assure pas notre indépendance d'abord
pour l'uranium j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais surtout d'en aura pas que
la Russie
c'est quand même une situation
préoccupante je rappelle qu'il y a plus
de 40% de nos de notre uranium qui
provient du Kazakhstan et du
notre pays voisins qui sont sous
contrôle de la Russie qui a le problème
du de la préparation des combustibles
dont 20% dépendent au niveau européen de
la Russie et une part pour nous aussi
parce qu'aurano ne fournit pas tout et
j'ajoute à cela ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait négligeable non plus que nous
continuons à envoyer tranquillement une
partie de nos déchets en Sibérie
et que compte tenu du problème vous avez
le patron de landra tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il parlera de manière beaucoup
plus savante que moi de la question des
déchets mais on a quand même un problème
imminent sur la table c'est qu'en 2030
lag est saturé
donc c'est pas là où on va coller nos
déchets supplémentaires que visiblement
les collectivités locales ne sont pas
forcément enthousiastes pour qu'ils
nouvelle piscine à lag que si géo se
heurte à beaucoup de difficultés et par
conséquent
cette dépendance vis-à-vis de la Russie
pour l'envoi d'une partie et pas la
totalité bien sûr d'une partie de nos
combustibles
usagers est un vrai problème vous me
demandez ensuite si l'évolution me
satisfait en tant qu'avocate bon je
dirais que l'avocate elle a pas grand
chose à dire là-dessus
je vous ai dit en commençant ce que
j'avais fait sur le nucléaire
donc c'est pas le c'est pas le tellement
le sujet si je puis dire
si je regarde depuis 2007 est-ce que je
suis contente pas contente d'avoir ça
pas beaucoup d'intérêt entre nous soit
dit mais en dehors de cela ce qui me
gêne je dirais le plus c'est que j'ai le
sentiment encore une fois qu'on ne tire
pas les conséquences des erreurs que
nous avons fait tout le monde fait des
erreurs c'est humain et rorum et raré ou
manounes persévérer
qui est grave et dans ce que j'ai pu
voir du fonctionnement de certaines
centrales dont une mission le président
qui vous est cher celle de Fessenheim
que j'ai vu quand même d'assez près si
je puis dire mais il y en a d'autres
très franchement il y avait des
problèmes non non minimes mais peut-être
tout à l'heure vous me posez des
questions sur Fessenheim et donc j'y
répondrai bien volontiers
alors ensuite vous m'interrogez sur ma
fonction ministérielle et le la
souveraineté et l'indépendance
énergétique au regard de cette fonction
alors je me suis permis de vous mettre
mon décret d'attribution d'où vous
verrez que son
chant sur le champ nucléaire est quand
même particulièrement étroit
j'avais la quotutelle de la sûreté des
installations nucléaires oui
les déchets oui
et puis basta pour le reste c'était les
énergies renouvelables et l'efficacité
énergétique donc je n'étais pas membre
si je puis dire associée à la définition
de la politique énergétique de la France
c'était pas ma compétence
donc je dirais que sur ce point je
répondrai je répondrai assez rapidement
je n'ai pas participé à des décisions
sauf sur Christmas huile dont on parlera
dans un instant
sur ce thème je n'ai aucun souvenir d'y
avoir participé j'avais pas de raison de
le faire puisque c'était pas c'était pas
ma compétence j'ajoute que entre 95 et
le il y avait le sujet des laboratoires
mais nous n'avons pas pris réellement de
décision au cours de cette période
puisque la décision de base avait été
prise en 93 et ensuite le choix de bure
c'est fait définitivement
en 97 après que toutes les communes
auxquelles ma successeur s'est adressée
pour essayer de coller un laboratoire
souterrain quel que soit leur couleur
politique on refusé poliment mais
fermement d'avoir le moins de
laboratoire souterrain chez elle donc en
fait le choix c'était Burbure c'était
pas très compliqué mais ça s'est passé
après mon arrivée alors sur la
préparation de l'avenir Burj vient de
vous expliquer le Pr ben je l'ai fait
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu comme je
pouvais mais à l'époque on était
vraiment au début et c'était avec
l'Allemagne je pense que le départ de
l'Allemagne de l'EPR de 6 mai ça quand
même été un coup de Trafalgar pour
l'industrie française
et
donc par contre je me suis occupé de
l'efficacité énergétique
de la transparence
de la prévention des accidents
et de la situation de la Hague qui est
assez préoccupante sur le plan de la
pollution
sur Super Phoenix
alors super Phénix je voudrais quand
même revenir sur un certain nombre de
points parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont franchement du domaine
du délire absolu
je rappelle que super Phénix a été
autorisé en 1977 le 12 mai 77 ouais tout
à fait exact
la première divergence a eu lieu le 7
juillet 1985 la puissance a été atteinte
en décembre 1986 en mars 1987 fuite dans
le barillet de sodium le je m'arrête un
instant il y a encore avec beaucoup de
simplicité dans les mots car je ne suis
pas ingénieur
mais j'ai visité Chris Malville donc je
sais un petit peu ce dont je parle quand
même
le système était celui d'un
surgénérateur c'est-à-dire l'objectif
c'était de n'avoir jamais besoin en
quelque sorte de recharger le
surgénérateur qui devait fonctionner
toute sa vie avec les mêmes crayons qui
se réactivaient en passant dans un bain
de sodium avec un barillet c'est à dire
un outil rond avec des trous comme un
barillet de pistolet et ça tournait et
ça tournait dans le bain de sodium sauf
qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
des fuites de sodium les fuites de
sodium c'est très embêtant
parce que le sodium ça brûle et ça brûle
méchamment donc au départ les ingénieurs
ont pensé que cette histoire de fuite de
sodium c'était une erreur de mesure
l'instrument de mesure puis au bout de
quelques semaines on s'est rendu compte
que malheureusement ce n'était pas le
cas donc 88
on arrête mars 87 on arrête tout
on vide le sodium
et ce surgénérateur qui n'en était plus
un se transforme en réacteur
avec un nouveau décret
du 10 janvier 1989
qui autorise la transformation
de cette installation qui était donc sur
générateur en réacteur
mais ça n'avait plus rien à voir avec un
sur générateur puisqu'il y a plus de
sodium et qu'on pouvait plus recharger
les crayons donc en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et bien il fallait aller
chercher les crayons dans le barillet
les sortir
en remettre d'autres à la place c'était
ça le la transformation et donc un arrêt
du Conseil d'État du
27 mai 1991 vous les trouverez les
arrêts je vous les ai sortis qui annule
le décret de 89 en considérant qu'il ne
pouvait pas être pris parce que
les
règles de fonctionnement n'avaient pas
été définis de manière suffisamment
stricte par le décret
rebelote si j'ose dire nouveau décret du
11 juillet 1994 donc pris par mon
prédécesseur et par Monsieur Balladur
qui affirme le caractère de prototype
avec un objectif de recherche qui prime
et ça c'est vraiment très important qui
prime sur les exigences d'exploitation
ce réacteur nouvelle mouture si je puis
dire il avait pas été fait pour
fonctionner comme ça donc il y avait des
vrais problèmes de sûreté qui se
posaient c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement d'Édouard Balladur avait
décidé de n'en faire qu'un réacteur de
recherche
lorsque je suis arrivé au gouvernement
j'ai demandé à Alain Juppé qui en a été
tout à fait d'accord
que soit nommé une commission
scientifique chargée d'évaluer le
fonctionnement de superficie c'est la
commission Castin vous trouverez le
rapport dans le dossier mais peut-être
vous le connaissez déjà tu ne sais pas
c'est le rapport de la commission
castain qui conclut avec trois types de
recherche pas qu'un pack de pack 3 qui
recommande le pack à le pack 3 mais
surtout pas le pack 2 et qui dit mais de
toute façon on peut en faire un
instrument de recherche c'est même assez
intéressant pourquoi pas
et donc c'est sur cette base qui était
partie le gouvernement mais avec des
coûts qui étaient quand même extrêmement
important et à l'époque l'idée c'était
de savoir si on pouvait pas faire de ce
cet ex sur générateur un incinérateur de
déchets radioactif c'était ça l'idée
notamment en s'appuyant sur les travaux
d'un Italien qui s'appelle le professeur
rou ça vous intéresse vous trouverez
tout ça dans le rapport dans le rapport
Castel
il est dessus un rapport de la Cour des
comptes alors malheureusement j'ai pas
pu vous le photocopier car il n'existe
plus sur internet donc la Cour des
comptes me l'a envoyé mais je ne l'ai
reçu qu'en arrivant à l'Assemblée
nationale qui est un rapport que vous
trouverez ou que je vous enverrai parce
qu'il est il vous le trouverez pas sur
le net qui est très intéressant mais qui
est extrêmement critique et qui dit en
fait il y a deux solutions où on fait
marcher Chris Malville jusqu'en 2000 où
on le fait jusqu'en 2015
jusqu'en 2000 il y a les autres
actionnaires de la NERSA la Ners a été
la société qu'ils aient fonctionné Chris
Malville qui paye
et dans ce cas là on est un coup de 60
milliards de francs
si on va jusqu'en 2014 là franchement la
Cour des comptes le dit pas sous la
forme que je vais utiliser mais
franchement c'est la plus grande
inconnue et on vous recommande vraiment
pas de faire ça
et surtout ça doit rester un outil de
recherche
là-dessus arrive le recours contre le
décret de 94 qui est jugé par le Conseil
d'État le 28 février
1997 donc vous trouverez l'arrêt
également que je vous communique
que dit le Conseil d'État conseil des
tailles dit votre décrétie légal parce
que ce que vous avez autorisé finalement
un outil de recherche
pour lequel la recherche prime
sur la production d'électricité
n'est pas le même que celui que vous
savez soumis en quête publique
parce qu'en cas de public vous avez
soumis un réacteur nucléaire
certes original mais un réacteur
nucléaire
et donc si on réautorisait ce à quoi
effectivement je me suis opposé j'avais
dit à la Juppé je présente ma démission
vous ne met un autre ministre de
l'Environnement il vous signera le
décret si vous le souhaitez mais moi je
ne cigarez pas pourquoi je voulais pas
le signe parce que redémarrer
immédiatement signifie le faire
redémarrer dans les conditions de
l'enquête publique c'est-à-dire sans
faire prévaloir la sûreté et la
recherche
sur la production d'électricité et donc
avec des garanties moindres il n'était
pas de fermer définitivement
christmasville l'idée était de faire
redémarrer ceux qui avaient été autorisé
en 94 avec une enquête publique qui
collait et donc finalement ce qui a
décidé Alain Juppé c'est d'interroger le
Conseil d'État sur le point de savoir si
la position que je défendais c'est à
dire on peut pas reprendre le même
décret sans passer par la case enquête
publique était valable ou pas valable
voilà ce qui s'est passé et donc en fait
j'étais dans la logique de la commission
Castin qui disait vous ne pouvez en
faire en fait qu'un instrument de
recherche et c'est ça qui doit primer
j'ai considéré que en faire autre chose
qu'un instrument de recherche
c'est-à-dire de le coupler au réseau
sans aucune sécurité particulière
présenter un risque j'étais chargé de la
Sûreté Nucléaire j'ai estimé que je ne
pouvais pas prendre cette responsabilité
voilà exactement ce qui s'est ce qu'il
s'est passé
maintenant vous verrez dans les
documents que je vous ai mis qui avait
quand même des critiques très sévères
sur le surgénérateur en considérant là
aussi que le saut qui avait été fait
entre Phoenix et super Phénix c'était
beaucoup trop important et vous avez
même le directeur de DF
qui dit je cite
voilà comme
la décision de construire superfélix a
été prise en 1974 président de def qui
parle dans un contexte de forte
croissance économique alors qu'il
devenait manifeste que les énergies
primaires ne seraient pas inépuisables
et que la France engagée un ambitieux
programme de centrales nucléaires au
préfixurisé toutefois on constate à
pestéruri que le passage direct d'un
réacteur de 250 mégawatts Phénix un
prototype de taille industriel de 1200
MW était un choix excessivement
optimiste et que la complexité de la
technologie a entraîné des surcoût d'un
investissement et des difficultés de
fonctionnement important voilà ce que
dit ce que dit EDF
donc voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire
sur
Chris Malville ensuite vous m'interrogez
sur la chaîne de décision pour les
raisons que je vous ai indiqué tout à
l'heure je peux être très Polyx
nucléaire militaire c'était évidemment
le domaine réservé du président de la
République donc j'ai jamais eu à m'en
occuper
sur le nucléaire civil
j'ai eu tout au long de l'exercice de
mes fonctions le sentiment que très
franchement le centre de décision
n'était pas au l'état mettez à EDF
j'en donnerai un exemple quand on a fait
le
premier rapport sur Chris Malville qu'on
avait besoin d'estimation financière
rapport castain l'état monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur ne
disposait pas de ses éléments
d'information Bercy n'avait rien les
seuls éléments d'information financière
c'était EDF qui les avait comment vous
les vous que l'État puisse décider en
toute connaissance de cause quand il a
même pas les éléments financiers qui lui
sont propres
même un problème
voilà moi c'est ce que j'ai c'est ce que
j'ai pu voir tout au long de mon passage
au gouvernement l'homme fort de l'époque
c'était monsieur sirota monsieur sireta
il était le patron de la Cogema et le
patron du corps des mines c'est lui qui
décidait en fait de la politique très
largement
parce que patron du corps des mines il
avait je dirais tous les ingénieurs des
mines et tous les responsables corps des
mines sous sa responsabilité c'est lui
qui était vraiment l'homme fort
autre exemple lorsque j'ai eu à gérer la
question du surnom de leucémies
infantiles autour de la Hague en 96
avant même que le ministère de la santé
et le prix ne réagissent
j'ai été assailli par un groupe informel
dans mon bureau composé de des
communicants tous azimuts de kojema de
DF tout ce qu'on voulait pour me dire le
type qui a fait le rapport vaut est nul
il est divorcé qu'est-ce que ça m'est
égal franchement quelle importance ça et
donc le type est sans intérêt et moi je
dis mais monsieur il y a qu'une chose
qui m'intéresse est-ce que vous avez un
compte une contre étude un rapport qui
me permette de dire notamment au maire
qui était quand même assez affolée en me
disant est-ce que mes enfants peuvent
aller se baigner sur les plages de lag
de leur donner une réponse en disant
mesdames vous pouvez y aller voilà nous
avons un rapport qui dit qu'il y avait
rien
donc j'ai demandé à ce qui est une
commission d'enquête qui enquête pour
savoir si cette étude valait quelque
chose ne valait rien du tout je pense
que c'était la seule réaction
rationnelle que l'on pouvait avoir pour
cela donc il y a une commission qui a
été nommée et 10 ans plus tard les
résultats de l'étude de 96 ont
malheureusement été confirmés tout ceci
pour vous dire que j'ai toujours essayé
de faire les choses de manière
rationnelle parce que vous posez vos
questions en disant mais est-ce que vous
êtes entouré d'experts ou globalement
est-ce que vous avez dans un coin de
votre bureau toute seule avec vous-même
décider de ce qu'il fallait faire
d'abord j'avais une équipe l'une numéro
de mon cabinet était un homme du corps
des ministres Renault à bord de
Châtillon
et j'avais un deuxième corps des mines
en la personne d'Olivier Hertz comme
conseiller technique donc je veux dire
que les questions industrielles ne
mettez pas étrangères deuxièmement
chaque fois que j'ai été en face d'un
problème encore une fois je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises je ne suis pas
ingénieur je ne suis que juriste j'ai
essayé d'être rationnel et de demander à
ce qui est des commissions scientifiques
ça a été le cas de la commission Castin
mais il y en a eu d'autres il y en a eu
trois que j'ai que j'ai nommé au cours
de ma mon ministère vienne me donner des
réponses quant à la question de la
préparation de l'avenir je ne saurais
mieux faire que de vous renvoyer à la
loi sur l'air que vous avez signé les
monsieur le Président sur l'air et
l'utilisation rationnelle de l'énergie
l'eau alors
parce que le changement climatique ne
nous était déjà pas inconnus il y a 25
ans on savait pas grand chose mais on
fait ça on savait quand même et donc
vous verrez que cette loi qui
globalement n'a pas été appliquée soyons
tout à fait clair
pour des raisons diverses et variées
contient notamment dans son titre 7 que
je vous ai mis vous verrez toute une
série de dispositions qui si elles
avaient mises en œuvre globalement nous
aurait fait gagner 25 ans vous aviez
l'électricité vous aviez le GNV vous
avez le contrôle de la consommation
énergétique vous aviez le DPE ça
s'appelle pas DPE mais c'est exactement
la même chose
vous avez les possibilités de changement
énergétique pour les
nos concitoyens vous aviez le fait de
favoriser les EnR et la cogénération
vous aviez ce qu'il fallait pour les
véhicules électriques et le GNV
notamment le question technique donc
tout ça n'a évidemment pas été appliquée
mais il n'empêche que nous avions pas
prévu un peu la préparation de l'avenir
dans cette loi sur l'air
je terminerai vous me demandez ce que je
pense de de la situation actuelle pour
vous dire je suis très franchement
inquiète sur notre situation
et sur le caractère quand même un peu
irrationnel des débats que nous avons
qui deviennent un peu d'ordre religieux
si je puis dire
c'est très difficile d'avoir un débat
sur ces sujets je pense que c'est très
important que cette commission a eu lieu
que vous puissiez entendre des gens
venus d'horizons très divers
la Commission du débat public qui se
tient actuellement sur pennlie peine à
se faire entendre alors que c'est
normalement un lieu où il devrait y
avoir un débat sur ce sujet parce que
c'est pas une question religieuse
c'est pas d'y croire ou de pas y croire
le sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'il y a mieux
pour notre pays quel est l'avenir
énergétique de la France c'est pas une
question religieuse c'est une question
rationnelle c'est une question politique
et économique
le
la position que je défends est
effectivement celle d'une massification
du renouvelable de toute façon dans tous
les scénarios je le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez dû renouvelables entre
60 et 100%
donc de toute façon il en faut il en
faut beaucoup
le problème avec le nucléaire c'est
quand même le problème à mon avis majeur
c'est le risque économique et financier
je me permets à cet égard d'attirer le
votre attention sur un sujet qui est
vraiment très important et dont on ne
parle pas et qui me paraît peut-être
elle risque le plus important pour EDF
c'est une
vous vous souvenez sans doute que sur
une klepoint monsieur Piquemal qui était
directeur financier à démissionné en
2013 ou 2014 je ne sais plus la date
exacte mais vous retrouvez ça facilement
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a démissionné bien
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur dans le contrat qui nous lie
aux Anglais il y a une clause
qui exclut l'application du prix garanti
dans l'hypothèse d'un retard trop
conséquent
dans la mise en place d'une clip point
or
la seule possibilité que DFA de s'y
retrouver un peu dans cette affaire-là
puisque je rappelle que dans la jungle
avec les Chinois c'est nous qui portons
le risque et pas les Chinois c'est
d'avoir un prix garanti à 120 euros le
mégawattheure c'est ce qui est prévu
imaginez ce qui se passe si ce prix
n'est plus garanti ça veut dire que
c'est contribuable français qui va payer
pour
les Anglais c'est ça que ça veut dire ça
c'est un risque financier qui est quand
même absolument vital et nous avons déjà
trois ans de retard sur une clé point
voilà donc je me permets de citer ce
point parmi beaucoup d'autres
et aussi insister sur un autre point qui
me paraît très important dans les choix
qui doivent être faits sur le tour de ce
qui est notre souveraineté nationale moi
j'ai une position qui est assez simple
peut-être qu'il faut paraître simpliste
mais je pense que
j'ai presque terminé je pense que là où
on est vraiment indépendance et avec
l'eau avec le vent et avec le soleil on
a acheté à personne c'est chez nous
le problème avec le projet qui c'est ce
qui se
c'est que nos EPR 2 on les aura allez en
2040 on fait quoi entre aujourd'hui 2040
on fait quoi si on continue à faire du
petit pas de chez petit pas en matière
d'énergie renouvelable
avec des coûts qui n'arrêtent pas de
baisser je vous ai mis également
les chiffres de l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie c'est pas les miens sur les
coûts le changement de coût entre les
différentes sources de production
énergétique le solaire et l'éolien
n'arrête pas de baisser maintenant on
est capable de faire des batteries les
gens vous vendent des toits solaires à
nos concitoyens avec des petites
batteries
le nucléaire n'arrête pas de monter le
choix que nous faisons que nous allons
faire est un choix qui est
financièrement extrêmement dangereux et
deuxièmement qui ne nous apporte aucune
solution à court et moyen terme 2040
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur c'est très loin et c'est
hypothétique
parce que certains soulignent le fait
qu'on y arrivera pas pour 2040 donc on
fait quoi voilà et ça ça me paraît
extrêmement important il y a aussi la
question j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
des des déchets et des risques
des risques liés aux accidents car il
est évident que plus notre parc vieillit
et plus le risque croit j'observe du
reste que le gouvernement a sorti dans
une très grande discrétion une
circulaire le 29 décembre
2022 donc il y a une semaine sur les
mesures radiologiques en cas d'accident
nucléaire musée radiologique des
personnes des citoyens bon donc c'est
évidemment un sujet qui est qui est sur
la table pour moi le sujet majeur c'est
vraiment la question économique et
financière on finance comment ce projet
et comment est-ce qu'on assure vraiment
notre indépendance et notre souveraineté
nationale
avec des coûts aussi énormes une
incapacité d'autofinancement et une
dette publique qui est celle que nous
connaissons voilà c'était un peu long
peut-être mais j'avais beaucoup de
choses à vous dire merci beaucoup alors
comme vous on va essayer d'avoir un une
méthode rationnelle et donc pour ma part
en tout cas les questions s'adresseront
davantage à l'ancienne ministre et à la
juriste qu'à la citoyenne puisque des
travaux de notre commission sont larges
et font un père à différents experts
donc on essaye de de circonscrire nos
échanges respectifs et successifs au
domaine au domaine
d'expertise mon ma première question
elle elle ferait peut-être appel un peu
à une projection dans dans le temps
passé qui est celui de l'exercice de
votre fonction ministérielle pour
comprendre un peu quel est l'état
d'esprit à l'époque du rapport notamment
vous disiez
que que la loi l'or qui a été finalement
celle dont vous avez été l'artisan en
Tracel et les premières prises en compte
de ces préoccupations la vision du du
rôle du carbone du CO2 dans le
réchauffement climatique parce que c'est
vrai que c'est assez surprenant
20 25 ans après à la lumière de ce que
la science nous a apporté depuis de se
reprocher dans certains débats de
l'époque où les écologistes finalement
prenaient le charbon enfin c'est ce qui
semble aujourd'hui assez invraisemblable
donc quel est la perception à ce moment
là du débat public de la question du
réchauffement climatique et du mix
énergétique vertueux pour pour
l'environnement alors je me souviens pas
monsieur le Président d'avoir jamais
prôné le charbon
j'ai été précis dans mes propos ça ne me
concernait pas moi
j'ai une question à Madame Lepage madame
l'ernos
mais écoutez écoutez madame bouanes sera
aussi auditionné en lui posera la même
question
que moi mais bon monsieur le Président
en 1995 nous étions au premier rapport
du GIEC
à l'époque et je m'en étais fait les
couilles évidemment
la l'augmentation de température
attendue était un degré 5 en 2100
je rappelle que le 1 degré 5 on y sera
dans 10 ans peut-être même un peu moins
donc les données n'étaient pas les mêmes
il n'empêche
que dans mon décret de compétence
j'avais demandé à Alain Juppé deux
choses d'avoir la compétence santé
environnement qui est une compétence
nouvelle et qu'elle est intéressé
personne parce que je pense que sinon je
l'aurais pas eu et deuxièmement de
m'occuper de cette question du
dérèglement climatique donc c'est
le sujet est dans le dans mon extrait de
compétence dans la loi sur l'air dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure vous avez dans
les dispositions techniques du titre 7
que j'ai rappelé je voulais pas être
trop longue donc je suis pas rentré dans
les détails mais vous avez toute une
série de mesures faites de dispositions
prises pour mesurer les émissions
carbonées pour les réduire dans les
constructions
dans tout ce qui était mobilier hors
automobile
pour les réduire dans les règles de
construction pour s'attaquer à la
publicité en faveur en décompte c'était
il y a 26 ans quand même
s'attaquer à la publicité en faveur de
tout ce qui était
énergivore si je puis dire donc tout ça
on l'avait tout à fait en tête sauf que
ça n'apparaissait pas avec la même
urgence qu'aujourd'hui bien évidemment
en fait je
le travaille qu'on essaie de mener c'est
de ne pas juger les actions du passé
enfin quand elles sont pas éclairées de
la même façon scientifiquement voilà
mais c'est juste de bien comprendre le
contexte aussi dans lequel son prix
certaines décisions
ça m'emmène finalement aux
questionnement sur quelle vision du mix
électrique vous disiez vous aviez le
nucléaire dans votre compétence donc ou
en partie juste sur la sûreté sur la
sûreté ça n'empêche que du coup on a un
regard quand même sur les enjeux la
sûreté c'est une petite partie du sujet
elle est pas négligeable mais c'est une
petite partie quelle est la vision du
mix électrique du rôle de l'électricité
dans le mix énergétique à l'époque
finalement assez déterminant dans la
compréhension qu'on peut avoir de la
façon dont tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président que j'avais fait voter une
disposition
pour que chaque habitation
puisse avoir son énergie de son choix
c'était pourquoi
c'était pour que le choix
de l'électricité ne soit pas univoque et
qui est notamment des cheminées parce
que s'il faisait pas de cheminée vous
pouvez pas avoir de chauffage au bois
c'est impossible donc non vous pouvez
pas donc l'idée c'était effectivement de
pouvoir favoriser le bois et il y a dans
la loi sur l'air une disposition par
exemple pour prévoir de favoriser les
constructions en bois disposition dans
le Conseil constitutionnel a xn est plus
tard déclaré qu'elle était à
constitutionnelle jamais compris
pourquoi mais enfin il y a une QPC
là-dessus et ceux qui ont fait l'ACC QPC
l'ont gagné voilà donc si vous voulez
l'idée du mix énergétique c'était
toujours que l'électricité évidemment
soit importante
mais on essayait de réfléchir aussi à
alors côté pollution de l'air si je puis
dire aux impacts de tout ce qui était
carboné notamment de l'essence et du
gazole
et donc il y a dans la loi sur l'air des
dispositions sur la fiscalité qui n'ont
jamais été appliquées sur la fiscalité
pour prendre en considération
précisément et l'impact carbone et
l'impact sanitaire des différents
fluides qui étaient utilisés donc on y
avait déjà pensé
vous trouverez tout ça dans le dans les
dispositions législatives
du coup ça mon menu une question pour
rester sur ce domaine là et de cette loi
l'or
bon après 97 il y a une alternance
et finalement elle n'est pas mise en
oeuvre et en 2008 avec le Grenelle
l'environnement grosso modo on remet les
mêmes questions dans la loi et on revoit
à peu près les mêmes à peu près la même
chose bon bah du coup qu'est-ce qui
entre 97 et 2008 du coup c'est dix
années là de votre point vous disiez
tout à l'heure dans votre propos
introductif vous avez peut-être un point
de vue sur les raisons pour lesquelles
elle n'a pas été mise en œuvre alors si
vous voulez monsieur le Président vous
êtes député vous savez comme moi que le
Parlement vote un certain nombre de
dispositions mais ensuite derrière il y
a ce qu'on appelle des décrets
d'application
et finalement
tous mes collègues vous diront que c'est
au stade des applications que les choses
se jouent si j'ose dire
et donc évidemment il y a des gens qui
étaient pas très contents de la loi sur
l'air c'est pas un mystère c'est ce que
je suis en train de dire donc ils ont
essayé bien sûr de regagner
en parler des graisses qu'ils avaient vu
perdre par la loi première observation
deuxièmement le sujet de la loi de l'air
n'intéressait pas vraiment Dominique
bonnet
pour quelle raison je ne sais pas mais
enfin c'est un fait et donc les décrets
d'applications traîné traîné traîner
traîner
ceux que j'avais pu faire passer mais il
s'est passé très peu de temps entre le
vote de la loi 30 décembre 96 et mon
départ du gouvernement 1er juin 97 donc
il y a deux décrets qui sont sortis de
mon temps si j'ose dire tout ce qui
concernait le contrôle de la pollution
de l'air les r Paris fait et qu'on sort
ça ça a été fait
mais par contre le puzzle qu'on avait
mis en place entre les
plans régionaux de la qualité de l'air
qui définissait des objectifs partez
d'un état zéro définir des objectifs
premier outil deuxième outil quand on a
les objectifs comment est-ce qu'on les
atteint deux outils le PPA le PDU le
Plan de Déplacement Urbain le plan de
protection de l'atmosphère sauf que les
décrets PPA et PDU sont sortis très très
en retard donc l'équilibre qui avait été
mis en place par la loi avec des délais
est tombé complètement à l'eau parce que
si les décrets PDU et PPA ne sortent pas
et que les perquia sont votés parce que
les percuas ont été voté relativement
comme il fallait parce que les décrets
étaient quasiment prêts vous perdez du
temps et du temps et en 2010 tous les
pépins étaient pas sortis
donc il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
retard beaucoup de retard à l'image
vous vous formulez tout à l'heure une
critique du marché européen de
l'électricité c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qui préoccupe beaucoup d'entre
nous aujourd'hui
vous avez formulé une critique enfin
c'est ça reste objectif et neutre comme
comme terme page
mais dans le sens
d'une politique énergétique française
qui était peut-être en retard sur
d'autres pays européens pourtant quand
on regarde les résultats et notamment
les émissions carbone
bien que nous ayons dû cet hiver
notamment importer massivement de
l'énergie de nos voisins notamment de
l'Est le système électrique français
reste un des plus décarbonés d'Europe
c'est juste donc est-ce que finalement
c'est pas une forme de contradiction
quant aux objectifs de décarbonation et
environnementale non monsieur le
Président tout le respect que je vous
dois
d'abord parce que l'énergie ne se réduit
pas l'électricité comme chacun sait donc
c'est vrai que nous avons sur le plan
électrique un très bon bilan grâce au
nucléaire mais nous aurions le même avec
des renouvelables soyons clairs
un peu comme les Allemands oui sauf que
les Allemands font beaucoup de charbon
encore mais il faut voir d'où ils
viennent et où ils sont
la critique sur les Allemands quand on
regarde le bilan on dit oui
effectivement il y a beaucoup plus de
tonnes de CO2 par
mégawattheure que chez nous c'est vrai
c'est tout à fait objectif mais il faut
ils ont baissé de 45% leur utilisation
du charbon quand même depuis 1990 donc
il faut voir d'où ils viennent
il n'empêche que nous ne sommes pas dans
les clous sur le plan de nos objectifs
climatiques nous n'étions déjà pas dans
les clous quand l'objectif était à 40%
en 2030
et ça c'est la décision du Conseil
d'État à Grande-Synthe comme vous le
savez je connais assez bien mais nous
sommes encore beaucoup moins dans les
clous avec les 55% d'où je me demande
vraiment comment on va pouvoir y arriver
donc on y arrivera avec de la sobriété
avec beaucoup plus de recours
effectivement au renouvelables pour
baisser notre consommation de gaz et de
charbon et de gaz et de pétrole d'où
l'intérêt de les mettre de la
méthanation c'est-à-dire du power to gaz
dont je parlais tout à l'heure qui est
formidable outil de même que le
développement de l'hydrogène vert vous
avez aujourd'hui des projets qui sont
formidables par exemple
tirer le père que monte un projet en
Espagne de fabrication d'hydrogène vert
dans une centrale qui aura la taille
d'une raffinerie de pétrole donc tout à
fait considérable un jeune ventcher avec
ArcelorMittal je sais pas si vous
connaissez ce projet avec ArcelorMittal
et un
je sais plus lequel pour faire des
engrais tout ça sera à partir
d'hydrogène vert donc il y a des choses
très intéressantes qui se qui se font
mais nous très franchement
on n'est pas en avance quoi mais du coup
quelle vision est-ce que quelle lecture
est-ce que vous faites finalement des
des scénarios
d'évolution de l'énergie et notamment du
besoin d'électricité qui ont été
produits ces dernières années on a vu
une rupture un petit peu dans dans ces
scénarios très récentes chez RTE est-ce
que finalement on sous-évalue pas au
regard des enjeux le besoin de
production d'électricité monsieur le
Président vous savez comme moi qu'on a
des objectifs
d'efficacité énergétique auxquelles
s'ajoutent aujourd'hui des objectifs de
sobriété énergétique c'est-à-dire qu'on
va devoir baisser singulièrement notre
consommation si je comprends bien votre
question mais si je la comprends pas
vous me corrigerez c'est est-ce que
on n'a pas sous-estimé les besoins
d'électricité au regard de
l'électrification remplaçant c'est ça
votre question si je comprends bien
remplaçant le pétrole et le gaz
honnêtement c'est possible mais pour le
moment la substitution d'usage ne se
traduit pas par une augmentation je
parle même pas de cette année où on a
une baisse pour les raisons qu'on
connaît de la consommation électrique
mais vous regardez sur les 10 dernières
années on a plutôt une stagnation mais
on n'a pas une augmentation
importante de la consommation électrique
pas du tout
donc en réalité le but du jeu c'est
probablement parce qu'on a du retard 1
peut-être justement parce qu'on a du
retard peut-être je ne sais pas mais
c'est très probablement de
d'arriver à produire
des
substituts du pétrole et du gaz
hydrogène encore une fois métanation et
de biogaz avec des systèmes propres qui
permettent effectivement une baisse de
notre consommation de fossiles et le
maintien d'une d'un niveau d'activité
économique compatible
deux dernières questions de laisser la
parole aux rapporteur je reviens sur
Chris Malville super Phénix sur
générateur
de ces différents petits noms
donc vous avez
très largement évoquer les sujets que
sur table
juste une petite question de précision
pour pour bien comprendre le niveau de
connaissances du dossier notamment à
votre arrivée au ministère est-ce que
c'est un dossier que vous aviez
préalablement traité notamment dans vos
précédents
notoriété publique donc je vais pas me
cacher derrière mon petit doigt oui je
connaissais bien ce dossier
je n'ai pas encore une fois la règle du
jeu c'était que ça fonctionne et je me
suis en rien opposé au fonctionnement
dans tout le temps où ça a fonctionné
j'ai simplement demandé la mise en place
de la commission Casta qui dure signé
trois ministres il y avait François
Bayrou et puis probablement au Borotra
on est assigné à Troyes où Yves galant
je sais plus quel des deux peu importe
on a signé à 3 cette commission qui
était faite avec Monsieur castain enfin
des scientifiques de très très bon
niveau qui ont conclu qu'il fallait
continuer et on a continué du coup juste
précisément quel était votre niveau et
de quelle nature était votre niveau de
connaissance du dossier super Phénix à
votre arrivée en tant que ministre
c'était une connaissance l'ivresse
c'est une connaissance livrée ce que
j'avais du dossier comme de beaucoup
d'autres centrales et beaucoup d'autres
installations
classées auquel lequel j'avais pu
travailler
mais encore une fois je n'y avais plus
strictement aucun intérêt personnel
j'avais plutôt un bon niveau de
compétence ce qui quand on arrive à un
ministère et franchement plutôt un atout
qu'un inconvénient me semble-t-il il y a
pas de valeur c'est juste
j'ai prêté serment donc je vous dis
vraiment la vérité il y a bien d'autres
installations que que je connaissais bon
je n'ai pas pris de position qui était
comment vous dire lier à ce que j'avais
pu défendre mais la connaissance que je
pouvais avoir du dossier des dossiers me
permettait d'avoir des vrais débats avec
mes interlocuteurs et notamment avec
midirections je suis un ministre qui
réalité en full timejob je réunissais
mes directeurs toutes les semaines
et y compris les directions qui
mettaient adjointe comme la direction du
sûreté des installations nucléaires et
donc la connaissance que j'avais des
dossiers notamment du clair mais pas que
encore j'avais quand même mon
portefeuille toutes les installations
classées me permettait d'avoir des vrais
débats ensuite on tranchait dans le sens
de l'État et de personnes d'autres
évidemment
dernière question pour moi
on parle beaucoup de la prise en compte
de du carbone dans la transition
énergétique de votre point de vue quel
est la réalité de la prise en compte du
coup je dirais matière notamment matière
première des des stratégies de
transition énergétique que nous avons
aujourd'hui ou peut-être même au regard
de votre expérience au fil du temps ces
20 dernières années
quand vous dites matières premières
c'est à dire les matières qui sont
utilisées
je ne suis qu'une juriste je ne suis pas
un ingénieur le sujet des terres rares
et des matériaux rares m'intéressent
beaucoup j'ai lu comme vous-même je
pense merci Monsieur le livre de
Monsieur Pitron qui est un peu la Bible
dans ce dans ce domaine
parce qu'évidemment c'est un sujet qui
touche à l'indépendance nationale mais
nous avons aujourd'hui de la recherche
chez nous en France qui fait que
on imagine des moyens de contourner la
difficulté par exemple
Renault pour ne pas le citer nous a
présenté une coloc que j'ai organisée
par E5 tel à La Rochelle l'année
dernière au mois de septembre une
batterie dans laquelle il n'y avait
aucune terreur
absolument pas aucune donc je pense que
ce qui est très important c'est
d'encourager la recherche développement
le sable on en a le silicium on en a
mais de faire en sorte précisément qu'on
trouve des technologies si possible
françaises à défaut européenne qui nous
permettent de contourner la question des
matériaux parce que effectivement la
dépendance mais je le sais pareil pour
l'uranium c'est pour ça que sur le
principe la question de surgénérateur
était intéressante je dirais que le pour
moi la décision la plus importante sur
cette question de la filière sodium et
neutron rapide c'est la rédastrite quand
même bon c'est la rédastrid je veux dire
que la fermeture demandait une enquête
publique sur Chris Melville c'est de la
roupie de sansonnet à côté de la porte
d'Astrid je veux dire que les
conséquences de strictement rien à voir
[Musique]
très bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour vos premières réponses
d'abord simplement avant de poser les
questions que j'avais prévues de vous
poser puisque vous avez prêté serment et
que c'était dans le champ d'attribution
au ministère je voudrais vous demander
de revenir sur un point qui me paraît
erroné mais j'ai peut-être une mauvaise
connaissance du dossier vous avez évoqué
l'idée que la France envoyait des
déchets nucléaires en Sibérie j'imagine
que vous faites référence à l'uranium de
retraitement qui est envoyé à la Russie
via un contrat avec rosatum pour lequel
le comité à la transparence sur la
sûreté nucléaire a clairement précisé
que ces allégations émises par
Greenpeace en l'occurrence était
parfaitement erroné et comme vous le
savez à la fois la loi française et
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale considère que l'uranium
de retraitement n'est pas un déchet
nucléaire donc j'imagine que vous
vouliez dire que ce que vous considérez
à titre personnel être un déchet est
envoyé en Russie
monsieur le rapporteur c'est un débat
juridique que vous ouvrez sur la
qualification de déchets parce que tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord là-dessus et
lorsque j'étais au Parlement européen où
j'ai vice-présidé la commission
Environnement c'est un débat que nous
avons eu sur le sujet de savoir ce qui
était un déchet ou qui ne l'était pas ce
qui a des conséquences juridiques et
économiques extrêmement importantes
comme vous le savez puisque le système
des provisions n'est pas du tout le même
si c'est un produit susceptible d'être
très utilisé ou pas voilà et le débat il
est autour de cela donc il y a un débat
juridique sur le point de savoir si ces
produits oui je ne vous contredis pas en
utilisant le mot produit non pas le mot
déchet peut-être qualifié de déchets ou
pas il y a un débat juridiques sur ce
point j'entends vous êtes avocate et il
y a une situation du droit
à l'instant T
qui puisse y avoir un débat prospectif
c'est une chose mais à l'instant t il y
a une situation juridique le débat reste
tout à fait ouvert monsieur le Président
au moins au niveau européen en l'état la
loi ne le considère pas comme un déchet
et d'ailleurs c'est pas un débat
juridique c'est une question c'est un
débat énergétique en matière énergétique
sous le contrôle des ingénieurs qui nous
écoutent peut-être pendant ces débats un
déchet c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
réutilise pas or l’uranium de
retraitement est utilisé pour devenir de
l’uranium de retraitement enrichi et
abonder des centrales donc même du point
de vue j'entends la question du débat
juridique mais je veux dire du point de
vue énergétique en l'état du contrat il
s'agit pas d'un déchet
le contrat passé avec rosatum peut-être
monsieur le rapporteur mais la question
est de savoir si la totalité de ces
produits je suis mesurée dans mon propos
et réutilisable ou pas et la totalité
des produits n'est pas réutilisée en cet
état une partie seulement oui c'est le
principe de la transformation mais en
tout cas je vous remercie de c'est ça le
problème de votre précision
je voudrais revenir sur un terme que
vous avez utilisé parce que
effectivement il a été beaucoup utilisé
par les interlocuteurs qui étaient en
fonction chez EDF ou à d'autres
responsabilités à peu près la même
période que vous parfois un peu
postérieure c'est celui de surcapacité
et en fait un certain nombre de nos
interlocuteurs quand on est revenu sur
ce terme nous ont dit effectivement on
utiliserait pas ce terme pour deux
raisons la première c'est que l'énergie
s'exporte et y compris sur le continent
européen et s'importe on en a fait le
bénéfice encore il y a quelques semaines
et puis la deuxième et ça évidemment
c'est un débat un peu postérieur enfin
en tout cas qui est apparu postérieure
c'est celui des prévisions
à nouveau c'est vraiment une question un
peu dans le sens de celle du président
tout à l'heure sur l'état d'esprit de
l'époque pour bien comprendre
vous étiez à la pointe du combat
écologiste politique vous aviez pour
ambition de faire baisser les gaz
émissions enfin les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ça c'était dans ma
compétence voilà non mais je veux dire
vous aviez enfin il me semble qu'en tout
cas vous vous aviez en tête l'idée qu'il
fallait réduire les énergies fossiles
qui émettait du CO2 et favoriser les
véhicules électriques ou absolument et
donc vous vous
vous plaidiez pour un monde enfin un
pays incontinent et un monde plus
électrifié oui c'est vrai et donc j'ai
je vous renvoie parce que c'est même pas
une question c'est ce qui m'apparaît
comme un paradoxe mais je suis sûr que
vous saurez le dénouer j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre comment on peut d'un
côté expliquer enfin utiliser la
surcapacité comme un argument pour faire
fermer ou ne pas ouvrir ou ne pas
prévoir l'installation de de centrale le
permettant et la question de la question
de l'électricité
simplement parce que il y a un problème
dans la question que vous posez
d'échelle de temps
lorsque j'étais au gouvernement il
n'était pas question de fermer des
centrales nucléaires monsieur le
rapporteur la question de se poser pas
ça ne se posait pas on venait de chaud a
été ouvert en 91 je crois j'étais
ministre en 95 la dernière elle avait 4
ans donc il était pas question de fermer
quoi que ce soit
la surcapacité elle a été conçue à la
base quand on a fait les centrales entre
73 et 90 le marché européenne
l'électricité n'existait pas ou en tout
cas pas sous cette forme là et donc
l'idée c'était quand même consommer chez
nous principalement l'électricité qu'on
ne stockait pas vous avez quand même 9
millions de logements chauffés à
l'électricité en France
donc quand vous regardez par exemple
une facture d'aménage allemand et une
facture d'aménage français le ménagement
va payer son 2 kWh ou 100 mw/h plutôt
qu'il a water beaucoup plus cher que le
ménage français mais ils vont utiliser
beaucoup moins
c'est à dire que nous avons si j'emploie
un peu trivial était biberonné à
l'électricité en été encouragée en
consommer autant qu'on en voulait
l'électricité qui était pas chère
ça c'était la période je dirais encore
quand j'étais quand j'étais au
gouvernement et c'est vrai que j'ai
essayé de décourager le chauffage
électrique pour passer plutôt à du bois
pas du fioul mais plutôt et du bois en
proposant justement qui des cheminées
c'est ce qui disposition de la loi sur
l'air qui n'a jamais été appliquée comme
un certain nombre d'autres mais enfin
voilà
ensuite dans les années cursus j'ai
jamais été contre l'électricité sauf que
il y a plusieurs façons de la produire
et donc moi je suis plutôt un défenseur
des énergies renouvelables et de
l'électricité produite à partir du
renouvelable donc il n'y a pas de
contradiction dans le fait de dire il
est souhaitable d'aller vers une et les
qualifications accrues qui ne signifie
qui peut s'exprimer en terme relatif ou
en termes absolu ici on baisse de
manière globale notre consommation
énergétique vous pouvez avoir une
augmentation de la part d'électricité en
valeur relative qui n'est pas forcément
une augmentation massive enfin leur
absolue c'est deux sujets qui sont qui
sont voisins mais qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes donc je
ne vois pas de contradiction enfin
j'espère ne pas en voir dans ma position
je vous remercie juste une du coup une
question une insiste parce que j'ai eu
un je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris vous
préfériez qu'on passe vous avez un
engagement très fort sur la qualité de
l'air et vous préfériez vous vous
poussiez à plus de chauffage au bois que
de chauffage électrique on est d'accord
qu'il y a quand même un impact assez
fort sur la qualité de l'air vous avez
raison mais d'abord on peut avoir des
sas de aujourd'hui je vous avais
beaucoup de chauffage au bois qui ne
pollue plus parce que tout simplement on
a les matériaux qu'il faut quand vous
mettez un insert il vous rejette pas de
particules fines et deuxièmement je
dirais qu'en 95 96 97 on n'avait pas
forcément les connaissances
scientifiques qu'on a aujourd'hui sur
les particules fines on était encore aux
particules fines au PM10 beaucoup moins
au PM de 5 et si on avait des éléments
sur le gazole sur le
le diesel merci sur le diesel parce que
il y a eu beaucoup d'études qui étaient
faites là-dessus les pollutions liées au
bois il y avait très peu d'études encore
à l'époque donc peut-être une manque de
connaissances de ma part mais qui était
un manque de connaissance je dirais
partager à l'époque c'était il y a 25
ans
je vous remercie
une question avant de venir à super
Phénix d'abord une question purement
factuelle mais vous verrez rapidement où
je vais en venir est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire à peu près combien de dossiers
en tant qu'avocate qui concerne le
nucléaire et en général si je me trompe
pas quand vous avez plaidé pour des
dossiers nucléaires c'était plutôt pour
la fermeture de centrales nucléaire à
peu près combien de dossiers
à l'époque c'était contre la
construction entre la construction
excusez-moi ou pour la pour l'arrêt ou
pour l'arrêt parce qu'il me semble que
vous avez plaidé pour pour super Phénix
en 89 91 et 93 contre oui c'était pour
la fermeture bah c'était pour
l'annulation du décret j'ai gagné hier
donc à peu près
est-ce que depuis est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner un ordre de grandeur du
nombre de dossiers sur les contre
lesquels vous avez appelé enfin pour
lesquels vous avez plaidé pour interdire
à peu près c'est pas énorme
c'est pas énorme parce que à l'époque on
avait beaucoup beaucoup de dossiers
d'environnement par exemple les dossiers
de la pollution du Rhin
qui est un dossier qui a duré pendant 15
ans qui était les rejets des mines de
potasse c'est un dossier beaucoup plus
important sur le nucléaire à peu près
j'en sais rien je sais pas vous dire
j'ai plaidé pour flamme en ville 1
Belleville mon client est Arnaud de
Voguet faut dire que à l'époque vous
aviez quand même une très forte
opposition de de fortes personnalité sur
le sujet
en autrui était une mère de
Belleville-sur-Loire il voulait pas de
non pas de communiquer cette commune
c'est à côté de Belleville il en voulait
pas Golfech c'était la famille Évelyne
Bailey qui était même cliente
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu d'autres
4 non
voilà c'est pas c'est des dossiers très
médiatique mais par rapport à l'époque
j'avais j'avais 500 600 dossiers samedi
quoi c'était vraiment pas grand chose
mais c'était des dossiers dont on parle
et dont on parlait beaucoup et comme je
vous l'ai dit jusqu'à 2007 je me suis
interdit de retoucher un dossier
nucléaire parce que pour moi la question
de du conflit d'intérêt il est beaucoup
plus après qu'avant c'est-à-dire le fait
qu'on puisse se dire que vous prenez une
décision parce que en sortant vous savez
que
or si j'ai refusé de personnes encore
une fois c'était pas légal il y avait
aucune disposition législative qui
m'obligeait à faire ça je l'ai fait par
rigueur personnel parce que je
considérais d'abord que c'était normal
et deuxièmement que ayant servi l'état
je voulais que se passe un délai
suffisant pour que les informations que
j'aurais pu avoir j'en ai pas beaucoup
honnêtement j'en avais pas beaucoup
parce que c'était pas dans ma compétence
soit obsolète et donc à aucun moment on
puisse imaginer que j'avais pu utiliser
des informations que j'avais connues
pour autre chose que ce pourquoi je les
avais connues c'est pour ça que je me
suis imposé un délai de 10 ans qui est
franchement très large par rapport à ce
qui est habituellement fait on voit des
gens qui vont s'occuper d'un secteur dès
qu'ils sortent d'un gouvernement merci
et est-ce que en parallèle vous pourriez
nous donner un ordre de grandeur du
nombre de dossiers qui concerne les
centrales à charbon ou à gaz ou pour
leur fermeture ou pour le non ouverture
ou pour évolution de leur fonctionnement
sur lequel vous avez
Gardanne pas le Garden actuel l'autre
et
c'est tout en fait c'est le pardon c'est
le prétexte à ma question qui est que
dans l'ensemble de vos déclarations
alors on n'a pas pu toutes les réunir
mais on a fait un grand travail et je
remercie c'est ceux qui ont fait ce
travail
il y a une sorte de
d'évidence que d'ailleurs reprise par
une formule que vous avez en 2002 qui
est je n'aime pas le nucléaire j'en ai
peur qui est que visiblement
vous visiblement vous vous enfin le
premier combat votre premier engagement
et bien contre le nucléaire et pas
contre les énergies fossiles et donc
d'une certaine manière dans vos
déclarations je vais pas les citer pour
être trop long si c'est pas ça
correspond pas le risque vous me vous
m'arrêterez j'ai l'impression que vous
opposez les énergies renouvelables et le
nucléaire et que et d'ailleurs vous le
dites je prends juste un ou deux
exemples parce que je trouve ça assez
parlant j'aimerais vous entendre
là-dessus vous dites
par exemple sur la rénovation le montant
des dépenses liées à l'isolation des
bâtiments et aux changements des modes
de le chauffage est prohibitif or le
lobby nucléaire veille au grain il a
fallu attendre 15 ans pour que le décret
d'application d'une disposition que
j'avais fait voter dans la voiture r
soit bien l'application 2014 ou alors
ou alors sur
je vous lis juste ou alors sur le soleil
ou en matière de solaire la France est
en retard mais fondamentalement c'est
parce qu'on ne veut pas avancer sur le
nucléaire sur le sur le solaire sur le
sujet puis après vous expliquer que
c'est parce que le lobby nucléaire s'y
oppose donc est-ce que vous pouvez
d'abord me confirmer que vous êtes vous
opposez bien le nucléaire aux énergies
renouvelables si oui qu'est-ce qui fait
que vous donnez la priorité à la lutte
contre le nucléaire plutôt qu'à la
fermeture de centrales à énergie dite
fossiles comme le gaz et le charbon et
ensuite est-ce que vous pouvez un peu
détailler les propos sur le lobby
nucléaire qui aurait ralenti les
économies d'énergie empêcher les
injections
d'abord je ne suis qu'un avocat donc je
défends ce qu'on me demande de défendre
je veux dire par là si personne ne vient
me demander d'attaquer une usine à
charbon je vais pas le faire comment
voulez-vous que je fasse bon donc je
suis tributaire des personnes qui
viennent me voir pour que je prenne en
charge leur dossier c'est pas moi qui
crée les dossiers voilà donc
effectivement la question de la
fermeture d'usinage de charbon
honnêtement dans ma carrière j'en ai eu
vraiment très très peu je me souviens de
Gardanne
mais c'est le seul cas donc je me
souvienne et très franchement il y a pas
eu beaucoup de cas contentieux de
fermeture d'usine de d'usines de charbon
franchement enfin moi je n'en ai pas
connu en tout cas et je vois pas
beaucoup de contentieux de contentieux
sur ce point là alors deuxièmement
pourquoi est-ce que j'ose renouvelable
et nucléaire
vous avez raison a priori il y a pas de
raison de les opposer sauf que dans la
vraie vie si je puis dire et l'état du
parc renouvelable français La Teste on
n'a pas été capable de faire les deux
tu n'as pas été capable de faire les
deux alors pourquoi moi j'ai une
explication
assez simple de cela
le marché de la consommation électrique
je le disais tout à l'heure est assez
stagnante en France il y a l'exportation
je suis d'accord avec vous mais
globalement tout ça est assez stagnant
si vous augmentez trop la part de
renouvelables on fait quoi d'un
nucléaire qu'on a du mal à vendre sur le
marché européen aujourd'hui enfin pas
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui puisque
malheureusement nous n'en produisons pas
beaucoup mais disons hier
alors que le marché européen est
organisé vous le savez comme moi pour
favoriser le renouvelable plutôt que le
nucléaire il nous est arrivé devant à
perte notre électricité nucléaire sur le
marché européen donc si vous voulez
favoriser trop le renouvelable enfin
favoriser le renouvelable en France le
développer pose un problème on fait quoi
de notre nucléaire donc c'est apparu
dans la vraie vie
comme franchement peut souhaitable et
donc moi j'ai vu ça de manière assez
concrète par qui s'opposaient aux
éoliennes j'écris de bouquins sur le
sujet donc je ne suis jamais cachée moi
je peux me reprocher beaucoup de choses
mais je suis une fille très honnête et
très carré donc je me suis jamais caché
derrière mon petit doigt
je pense que on n'arrivera pas on n'est
pas arrivé à faire les deux et qu'on
n'arrivera pas à faire les deux parce
que financièrement on n'arrivera pas à
monter à 40 ou 50% de renouvelables et
faire le programme nucléaire que l'on
veut faire avec le grand carénage avec
la question des déchets et avec la dette
actuelle d'EDF je ne vois pas comment on
finance ça c'est pour ça que je ne vois
pas comment on fait les deux monsieur le
rapporteur c'est une question pratique
aux pratiques si vous me démontrer que
oui il y a aucun problème qu'on a les
250 milliards ou je sais pas combien
pour faire les deux pourquoi pas
que je ne pense pas que ce soit le cas
et deuxièmement je vais vous dire
quelque chose quand j'étais ministre de
l'Environnement je n'ai jamais été
inquiète pour la sûreté de nos
installations nucléaires jamais
c'était ma compétence je n'ai jamais été
inquiète parce que nous avions un niveau
de compétence et de sérieux qui faisait
que comme ministre franchement un
ministre de dort jamais sur ces deux
oreilles c'est pas vrai mais j'étais
assez tranquille ce n'est plus le cas
ce n'est plus le cas et depuis déjà un
petit paquet d'années
je n'ai plus du tout cette tranquillité
là et il a fallu quand même attendre
2010 ou 2011
2011 Fukushima pour que le président de
l'ASM reconnaisse qu'un accident
nucléaire en France était possible quand
on a monté les centrales nucléaires vous
êtes évidemment trop jeune pour le
savoir
mais
à l'époque pour les premières centrales
on vivait sur ce qu'on appelait le
rapport asmucène je pense que vous en
avez entendu parler ce rapport race
mucène disait que le risque était d'un
accident tous les 22000 ans sur la
planète entière
moi le sérieux de ce rapport il
n'empêche qu'on a vécu là-dessus et que
quand on a fait notre programme
électronucléaire l'idée qu'un accident
nucléaire a pu se produire en France
c'est quelque chose de absolument
inenvisageable
et il a fallu attendre 2010 ou 2015 pour
qu'on se dise bah oui mais un peu ça
peut peut-être nous arriver quand même
cette histoire là et de commencer à
avoir des évaluations des coûts en cas
d'accident nucléaire et c'est vrai que
même si aujourd'hui devant vous j'ai
beaucoup insisté sur la question
économique et financière parce que dans
le choix énergétique c'est quand même ce
qui m'apparaît aujourd'hui le plus
important la question du risque
elle ne doit pas être totalement passée
sous silence et répondre au risque c'est
aussi une question d'investissement
Fukushima s'est passé en 2011 les stress
test ont été faits en 2012 nous sommes
en 2023 toutes les mesures postes
Fukushima ne sont vous le savez mieux
que moi toujours pas mis en place dans
toute nos centrales françaises
en fait ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
comment vous pouvez être plus inquiète
aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque vous exerciez
vos fonctions alors que depuis il y a
une autorité de sûreté indépendante il y
a eu un audit poste Fukushima et la
sûreté a été augmentée je sais le
relatif que je comprends pas qu'est-ce
qui fait que vous êtes plus inquiète
aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque alors que
fait très sérieusement son travail même
si il m'arrive de temps en temps dire un
mot dessus je pense qu'elle fait très
sérieusement son travail et je crois
comprendre pourquoi
l'autorité de santé nucléaire vous le
savez est une autorité indépendante mais
elle a une particularité je ne sais pas
si vous la connaissez elle n'a pas de
personnalité morale
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire n'a pas
de personnalité morale ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'en cas de pépins
comme l'état n'est pas pénalement
responsable qui est responsable les
personnes physiques
c'est-à-dire le président et les membres
de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
je pense que cet élément n'est pas
totalement négligeable
dans le sérieux avec lequel la SN fait
son boulot
j'observe cependant qu'elle est pas
toujours informée voyez la procédure
pénale qui est au Tricastin actuellement
en cours
j'ai moi-même eu un certain nombre de
confidences que je ne rendrai pas public
puisque c'est des confidences et que
Julie parle le secret professionnel
sur des inquiétudes que peuvent avoir
des salariés sur les centrales
nucléaires je parle pas des voisins ni
de ce que les uns ou les autres peuvent
penser qu'ils savent pas forcément
où vous exercez votre secret
professionnel et vous faites pas état de
ces inquiétudes ou des inquiétudes elles
sont pas elles sont consommés
tard donc je considère que vous nous en
faites état ou on évoque pas
c'est un exemple extrêmement concret
vous savez que j'ai travaillé sur
Fessenheim vous savez que je travaille
sur objet tout ça n'est tout à fait
public donc ça veut dire que j'ai
regardé les dossiers de manière
attentive et que je peux me poser un
certain nombre de questions et sur
d'autres centrales sur lesquels je ne
travaille pas puisque je ne travaille
aujourd'hui que sur Bugey sans aucune
autre donc les choses sont tout à fait
claires
et bien
sur d'autres centrales parce que je lis
quand même un peu je me tiens au courant
de ce qui sort je me pose je me pose des
questions je me pose des questions
parce que je ne suis pas certaine que le
niveau de compétence actuel c'est une
question de compétence je ne pense pas
qu'il soit celui qu'on avait en 1995 je
suis désolé de vous le dire sur cette
forme là mais c'est ce que je crois
je vous remercie Jean-Pierre mon dernier
point sur superhénix donc vous avez
largement détaillé donc je vais juste à
l'essentiel avec deux questions la
première et ni voyait vraiment pas de ma
liste de ma part c'est en 1989 1991 et
1993 vous plaidez pour l'annulation du
décret pour faire en sorte je résume
pour le grand public simplement que
super Phoenix ne rouvre pas enfin
d'aucune manière et vous arrivez au
responsabilités
93 et vous arrivez au responsabilités et
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure par
loyauté et garde tout vraiment ça je mon
travail et enfin mon le devoir que je
m'impose c'est de faire en sorte que
cela fonctionne et vous arrivez enfin je
veux dire pardon c'est une question
probablement naïve d'un jeune député
mais vous avez combattu
ardemment et avec beaucoup de passion
pour que super Phénix soit un lointain
souvenir et vous arrivez aux
responsabilités en charge notamment de
la Sûreté Nucléaire et vous mettez votre
à ce que super Phénix fonctionne
mais monsieur le Président
pardonnez-moi mais ça n'a rien à voir un
avocat défend la cause de son client
j'ai défendu la cause de mes clients
j'ai gagné du reste à tous les coups
89 et 91
97 j'étais plus là donc c'est pas moi
qui gagne c'est celui qui m'a succédé à
savoir mettre mandelka mais
donc ce que je disais était pas
totalement idiot je veux dire par là il
y avait des questions juridiques j'ai
défendu des questions juridiques bon
c'était procédural tout ça
c'était totalement procédural j'arrive
au gouvernement mon boulot n'est pas de
défendre un cas mon boulot c'est
d'assurer la sûreté des installations
nucléaires c'est ma compétence donc
d'assure de participer à la sûreté des
Français
j'ai pas d'autres sujets que celui-là je
suis au service de mes concitoyens et
loyal a un gouvernement qui souhaite que
cette centrale fonctionne donc elle
fonctionne point barre voilà je pense
qu'il est important quand on rentre dans
des fonctions je ne sais pas quel était
monsieur le rapporteur votre fonction
avant d'être député mais
serviteur de l'État vous restez dans
l'état si je puis dire mais avec une un
regard différent quand vous venez du
privé et que vous arrivez à une fonction
publique si vous n'êtes pas capable
d'abandonner ce que vous faisiez avant
non pas forcément vos idées mais ce que
vous défendiez parce que c'est votre
métier de défendre ce moment-là il y a
un problème
donc je n'étais plus avocate je n'avais
pas défendre cette cause là plutôt
qu'une autre j'avais à assurer la sûreté
des installations nucléaires et donc de
m'assurer de la sûreté de Christ
Malville le rapport castain nous dit
très clairement ça peut fonctionner sous
forme d'instits de recherche
donc moi ça me suffisait ça fonctionnait
sous forme de centre de recherche
lorsqu'en 97 le Conseil d'État annule et
que le redémarrage impose que ça ne
puisse plus être un centre de recherche
là je dis je suis désolé je suis pas
d'accord mais c'est totalement lié à ce
que c'est ce que c'était ce qu'avait dit
la commission Castin les choix
qu'avaient fait le gouvernement auquel
j'appartenais d'en faire un centre de
recherche je vous ai mis deux trois
coupures de presse vous verrez je
n'invente rien là-dedans et c'est
totalement distinct de ce que j'avais pu
faire avant en défendant des intérêts
qui n'étaient pas forcément privés des
hommes et qui n'était pas ce d'État et
là je n'étais là que pour défendre les
intérêts de l'État et aucun autre alors
justement je pense vraiment avoir été
quelqu'un qui avait le sens de l'État
justement en février 1997 le Conseil
d'État annule ce décret au motif qui a
un décalage net c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué
qu'il y a un décalage net entre peut le
fait que entre la production électrique
et la recherche est-ce que vous pouvez
nous décrire ce qui se passe ensuite
avec le trio si je peux me permettre qui
que vous faites avec le ministre en
charge de l'Industrie et le Premier
ministre il y a sauf erreur de ma part
plusieurs possibilités la possibilité
qui est celle qui est retenue c'est
celle de ne pas rouvrir et donc de
d'arrêter le d'arrêter super Phénix il y
a la possibilité il y a la possibilité
de prendre un nouveau décret pour mettre
en adéquation la nouvelle fonction de
super Phénix afin du point de vue
décrétale avec la réalité technique ce
qui suppose une enquête publique de
quelques mois là
j'entends et c'est sur sûrement pas une
avocate que je vais dire ça mais
j'entends la question du droit mais il y
a au fond la failli la question du fond
et donc quels sont les discussions que
vous avez avec le ministre en charge de
l'Industrie le mini et le Premier
ministre est-ce qu'ils sont parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'avis est-ce qu'ils sont
favorables et vous même est-ce que vous
portez une position au-delà du point
strictement juridique qu'on a bien en
tête monsieur le rapporteur n'était pas
de fermé Chris Malville c'était de faire
une enquête publique je vous ai mis dans
le dans le dossier je vous remette les
coupures de presse du monde de l'époque
où j'avais fait une interview vous
verrez j'ai une position qui est pas du
tout en ferme Chris Malville c'est on
fait une enquête publique et pourquoi
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure parce que
si on ne la faisait pas on ne repartait
pas sur un outil de recherche mais bien
sur un outil dont la fonction première
était de produire de l'électricité j'ai
pas eu de débat avec le ministre de
l'Industrie j'en ai eu évidemment avec
Alain Juppé qui aurait aimé qu'on
court-circuite qu'on bipasse l'enquête
publique que je signe le décret sans
enquête publique et ça j'ai dit que je
ne le ferai pas mais j'ai pas demandé la
fermeture de Chris Malville donc vous
n'avez pas pour être sûr de bien un
décortiquer le fil des évents vous avez
pas de discussion avec le ministre en
charge de l'Industrie du tout non
un peu surprenant non non
ça se passe directement avec le Premier
ministre c'est un décret qui devait être
consigné
avec le Premier ministre le ministre
l'industrie et moi-même peut-être
d'autres d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
et donc moi j'ai à faire informer le
Premier ministre que je ne signerai pas
je l'ai informé ça s'est passé un
vendredi je l'ai informé dès le vendredi
soir je ne l'ai pas eu lui je me suis
Gourdeau montagne le Premier ministre à
Bordeaux et je lui dis je voudrais voir
le Premier ministre mais moi je ne signe
pas mais je comprendrais tout à fait que
vous me remplaciez il y a strictement
zéro problème si vous souhaitez que je
dépose ma pause ma démission je vous
offre ma démission immédiatement pour
pas perdre de temps
j'estimez-moi que je ne pouvais pas
signer ça non pas parce que j'avais
défendu avant Chris Malville c'était pas
le sujet mais parce que le redémarrage
immédiat imposait que ça ne soit plus
un centre de recherche privilège dans la
recherche mais si ça fabrique
d'électricité quand même mais ça
impliquait que ce soit avant tout une
centrale de production d'électricité
j'étais je considérais que je ne
défendais pas la sûr français en
acceptant ça c'est tout ça n'a pas
d'autre objet que celui-là et donc Alain
Juppé à saisi le Conseil d'État pour lui
demander son avis sur le fait que on
pouvait prendre un décret nouveau
concernant sa plus dans la recherche ou
pas je lui ai dit c'est pas possible si
vous appliquez l'arrêt du Conseil d'État
vous ne pouvez pas alors on n'aura
jamais la réponse monsieur le rapporteur
puisque nos successeurs ont décidé de
fermer et on demandait au Conseil d'État
de parents de son avis donc je ne sais
pas quel aurait été cet avis mais donc
ce que vous dites c'est que ce que vous
exposez à vous Premier ministre à
l'injupé les deux solutions qui vous
paraissent enfin les trois solutions qui
vous paraissent raisonnables un
redémarrage sec pour reprendre des
propos précédents c'est-à-dire faisant
fille d'une nouvelle enquête publique
auquel cas vous remettriez votre
démission deuxième option
simplement ce qui s'est produit c'est à
dire rien et troisième option une
enquête publique une nouvelle enquête
publique
j'expose les trois possibilités et vous
c'est la possibilité que vous préconisez
et Alain Juppé le Premier ministre à
l'époque refuse de lancer une nouvelle
enquête publique c'est ça ce que vous
nous dites
s'il est obligé de le faire
et entre temps la solution de
l'Assemblée donc voilà ça s'est passé
comme ça mais encore une fois je vais
être tout à fait clair monsieur le
rapporteur j'ai pas demandé la fermeture
de Fessenheim j'ai demandé une nouvelle
enquête de Griezmann
excusez-moi
vous avez
je vous ai mis une la coupure du monde
je pense dans le
j'ai bien en tête c'était ma question
portait bien sur la réaction
madame Lepage demande à Monsieur Juppé
une enquête publique sur son père
Phoenix
voilà j'ai rien demandé d'autre que ça
parce que c'était l'application de
l'arrêt du Conseil d'État
merci beaucoup merci madame la ministre
pour ces exposés ces questions alors
effectivement moi j'aimerais revenir sur
le temps des centrales nucléaires vous
avez évoqué au tout début qu'il était
estimé à 30 ans 40 ans puis vous avez
également dit 50 ou 60 ans moi je suis
député de l'Ain donc concernés par la
centrale du budget pour lequel vous avez
vous portez un recours au nom de la
République du canton et la Ville de
Genève des citoyens français aussi et je
crois qu'effectivement il y a d'autres
d'autres personnes dedans et pourtant et
pourtant vous avez l'air dans vos propos
de penser que une vie centrale nucléaire
peuvent aller au-delà des 30 ou 40 ans
qui sont évoqués il y a une demande de
PR2 sur sur cette centrale si je
voudrais avoir votre votre avis sur le
fait de du renouvellement des réacteurs
et effectivement des centrales peuvent
arriver au bout à un moment donné et
comment est-ce que vous avez vous
fonction de ministre envisageait cette
fin des réacteurs et s'il y avait
évidemment une volonté de les voir
renouveler sur sur les installations
vous avez parlé des accidents en
nucléaires à mon sens il renforce ils
ont renforts permis de renforcer la
sûreté nucléaire et d'ailleurs les
technologies ont permis de détecter les
corrosion sous contrainte plus récemment
et puis alors sur le deuxième point donc
ça c'était ma première question
concernant la durée des réacteurs et ma
deuxième question au titre de l'OPEX
donc je porte un rapport sur la sobriété
vous l'avez évoqué notamment sur la
déporter une politique de maîtrise de
l'énergie ce qui avait été déjà fait
dans dans le passé qu'elle serait vos
vos points à remettre en en
perspective on va dire alors peut-être
de cette commission d'enquête également
dans la maîtrise de l'énergie et ce qui
aurait pu être fait sous la loi alors et
qui n'est toujours pas fait je vous
remercie beaucoup il y a beaucoup de
questions de votre question dans vos
quêtes dans votre question madame la
députée je vais essayer de n'en oublier
aucune
sur la durée de vie il est clair qu'en
95 la question de la durée de vie des
centrales ne se posait pas
la plus vieille avait divergé en 78
donc elle avait même pas 20 ans
donc le question de se posait pas
la première fois où je l'ai vu vraiment
aborder c'est dans le rapport de lopex
de 99 donc j'avais quitté mes fonctions
quand il s'agit de la rente nucléaire et
du renouvellement
ça n'empêchait pas de penser à l'avenir
et de penser à l'EPR dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure mais il n'était pas
question
d'envisager plus de 30 ans à l'époque le
sujet n'était pas sur la table
pourquoi est-ce que
les 40 ans parce que on y est déjà
madame le député on y est
budget c'est 78
donc c'était catonce depuis 2018 budget
à 40 ans
voilà
nos centrales elles ont été faites pour
30 ans
vous l'avez dur dans le rapport de
l'OPEX de 99
monsieur Gallet et Monsieur Biraud
distrait clairement on a conçu nos
centrales pour 30 ans et à l'époque
c'était effectivement la durée de vie
prévue même si même si dans notre
dispositif juridique il n'y a pas de
délai de validité des autorisations de
centrales nucléaires
c'est pas c'est pas prévu par contre il
y a les visites décennales et dans la
loi maintenant pour au-delà de 45 ans il
y a obligatoirement une enquête publique
et j'ai cru comprendre qu'il était
question de remettre ça en cause enfin
pour le moment la loi prévoit prévoit
cela et vous avez les dispositions
communautaires
de la directive sur la sûreté nucléaire
qui fixe à certains nombre de règles
avec notamment un arrêt qui a été rendu
par la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne
à propos des centrales de bulles en
Belgique qui prévoit que le
renouvellement au-delà de 40 ans de la
centrale de bulle était soumis à une
étude d'impact voilà donc il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui qui se
mettent en place si vous voulez nos
centrales c'est du béton c'est de
l'acier sa vie c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait normal
donc
à mon sens plus on attend plus il y a un
risque donc c'est très important
que
l'autorité de santé nucléaire et les
moyens de faire son travail
convenablement et que Def et les moyens
d'entretenir convenablement nos
réacteurs parce que pour la raison que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire
celle du délai
qui s'écoule entre maintenant et le
moment où éventuellement il y aurait EPR
2 on est
quelque chose en termes de l'électricité
parce que même si on entend puissance en
renouvelable moi je j'aimerais bien
qu'on soit 40 % en 2030 je crois pas
trop mais ça veut dire encore une grosse
part de c'est encore 60% nucléaire donc
il faut qu'on ait des centrales qui sont
en état de en état de fonctionnement bon
sur un nouveau réacteur il nous a pas
échappé que je n'y suis personnellement
pas favorable donc je militerai pas en
faveur 2 mais ça c'est la position de la
citoyenne je n'ai plus aucune aucun
qu'une fonction politique donc c'est pas
moi de décider mais pour les raisons que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est un choix
financier et économique franchement
extrêmement redoutable
je sais bien vous allez me répondre mais
vous me l'avez pas dit les uns et les
autres que on fait du nucléaire dans le
monde oui c'est vrai on en fait mais
personne au niveau auquel nous sommes
nous
donc
voilà personne n'a plus de 50 % de
réacteurs non été à 70% de l'électricité
nucléaire alors ensuite sur le rapport
sur la sobriété
c'est un très bon sujet c'est un sujet
vraiment très important donc c'est bien
que l'assemblée sans préoccupe comment
est-ce qu'on passe de l'efficacité à la
sobriété
ce n'est pas exactement la même chose
et je dirais que jusqu'à présent sur
l'efficacité n'a pas été terrible quand
même
l'Agence pour la maîtrise de l'énergie
elle a été créée dans les années 70 ou
quelque chose comme ça
mon âge me permet de vous dire que en 73
on a fait vraiment des choses
vraiment
et puis ensuite
la politique a été de d'être riche et
prolixe en matière d'électricité donc et
plus préoccuper de quelques efficacité
que ce soit et plus on consommait
d'électricité et mieux se portait donc
on a fait peu d'efficacités et à
fortiorer la sobriété est un terme que
nous concitoyens découvrent avec
stupéfaction si je puis dire sauf que
c'est par là qu'il faudra passer alors
l'aspect positif pour moi de la sobriété
outre le fait que toute façon c'est
incontournable c'est quand même c'est
une source de transformation économique
et technologique absolument remarquable
il y a tellement de choses à faire
sans vivre moins bien en vivant
simplement un peu différemment
on peut tout à fait faire donc c'est
assez je trouve que c'est quelque chose
d'assez dopant en réalité
monsieur Falcon je crois si vous avez
une question
oui je vous remercie monsieur le
Président bien écoutez j'ai écouté j'ai
écouté avec la tension votre plaidoyer
quasi religieux pour le les énergies
renouvelables ce qui confirme un petit
peu nos craintes quand votre quant à
votre compte à votre participation dans
la minoration de la part du nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique français
nous avons un peu le sentiment que vous
portez une part de responsabilité dans
la situation énergétique des astrueux
dans laquelle se trouve la France
aujourd'hui et je dis cela en prenant un
témoin plusieurs décennies de combat qui
de votre combat qui semble aller dans ce
sens vous avez votre cabinet d'avocats
qui est une référence dans le conseil
auprès des producteurs éoliens vous avez
également comme client le canton de
Genève qui attaque la centrale de budget
et nous interrogeons également sur votre
argumentation pour justifier la
fermeture de de super Phénix en mettant
en avant des problèmes de sûreté ce qui
ne semble pas être la position de tous
et
contenu tout cela madame Lepage nous
pensons que parisiologie vous avez
largement joué un rôle moteur dans le
dépeçage de la filière nucléaire
française et le
[Musique]
l'exposé que vous avez fait aujourd'hui
semble confirmer cela voilà je vous
remercie
je vous entends monsieur le député vous
nous sommes heureusement démocratie vous
avez le droit de penser ça et moi je
dois penser à autre chose
je pense que en tant que ministre je
n'ai participé à rien du tout qui réduit
la filière française et je pense me
mettre largement expliqué sur ce point
j'ai même plutôt encouragé le Pr comme
je le disais tout à l'heure
sur le reste vous m'imputez mes
activités professionnelles qui sont ce
qu'elles sont je pense que là aussi on a
démocratie on a le droit de défendre qui
ont vu et comme on veut ça fait partie
de la démocratie et comme en plus le
Conseil d'État m'a souvent donné raison
je pense que ce que je défendais était
pas totalement absurde voilà pour le
reste très franchement
oui je suis un défenseur mais pas
religieux du tout
j'espère avoir prouvé que j'avais plutôt
une approche pragmatique des choses et
irrationnelle
oui je défends les énergies
renouvelables parce que je pense que
c'est bien pour notre pays c'est tout
j'ai pas de religion j'ai pas de
religion là-dessus franchement aucune
voilà
j'ai défendu très peu d'éoliens je
défends beaucoup plus de solaire que
d'éolien voilà et je vais même ajouter
une charge supplémentaire sur mon dos
j'aide au montage de projets solaires en
France et j'en suis extrêmement content
voilà merci Madame Leernes
oui merci vous avez été on est
auditionné un certain nombre de d'autres
personnes avant vous pour effectivement
identifier la vulnérabilité française
puisqu'on parle de souveraineté et
d'indépendance énergétique et notamment
sur le poids du nucléaire qui aurait et
qui a opéré en tout cas vous l'avez
confirmé dans vos propos
le fait qu'on est une réglementation
thermique moins probante et qu'on ait
été dans une surconsommation
d'électricité avec une dépendance sur
les pics notamment à l'électricité je
voulais vous interroger sur la place des
lobbys nucléaires puisque vous en avez
fait état dans des un certain nombre de
nouveaux ouvrages et puis dans vos
différentes fonctions j'ai envie de dire
puisque vous avez été ministre et donc
j'imagine que vous avez là aussi vécu de
près les lobby nucléaires vous avez dit
en propos préliminaires que notamment
les décisions c'était pas l'état qui
était prenait mais bien EDF donc c'est
une question en tant que ministre en
tant au Parlement européen vous y avez
fait référence également puisqu'il y a
eu pas mal de débats notamment sur la
taxonomie etc donc je pense que c'est
intéressant de voir les lobbies aussi à
l'oeuvre à cet endroit là et puis sur le
nécessité d'avoir un débat rationnel et
apaisé sur la question du nucléaire et
notamment vous avez évoqué les pages de
publicité contre les énergies
renouvelables le week-end dernier mais
également les trolls dont je viens de
découvrir aussi la puissance nous avons
interrogé puisque nous avons dans les
personnes auditionnées aussi vu des
responsables de la semaine qui ne
souhaitaient pas donner une transparence
sur ni leurs moyens ni les contributeurs
ni conseil d'administration j'ai reçu
moi-même de nombreuses voilà vrais de la
voix du nucléaire et donc ma question
c'est comment avoir un débat apaisé en
France sur la question du nucléaire la
puissance
et des lobbys sur cette sur ce débat
effectivement qui ne
qui semble être une croyance absolue et
fermente alors que les faits démontrent
le contraire
c'est une première question vraiment
basée sur les lobbys j'ai une autre
question qui concerne vous y avez
personnellement répondu mais la
dépendance française du fait de la voix
unique sur nucléaire non seulement sur
l'efficacité énergétique et les retards
énormes en termes d'énergie
renouvelables mais aussi sur la
dépendance extérieure vous avez évoqué
la Russie j'ai moi-même interrogé la
ministre de l'Énergie aussi sur les
cargos qui font des allers-retours
aujourd'hui malgré l'embargo sur les
autres produits énergétiques donc
d'exception du nucléaire et également
sur la question des leucémies infantiles
à la Hague nous avons interrogé aussi
madame louverjon qui s'est exprimé en
disant qu'il n'y avait rien qu'elle
avait mis des caméras pour prouver qu'il
n'y avait rien et moi je m'interroge
aussi sur la question de Tchernobyl du
nuage qui n'a pas passé les frontières
et donc comment le lobby nucléaire là
aussi peut infl passer sur la non ou le
non résultat des en fait des études
épidémiologiques qui devraient y avoir
en bonne et due forme
pareil sur le prix d'énergie comment se
fait-il qu'en France on soit persuadé
que c'est grâce au nucléaire qu'on
aurait une énergie peu chère alors ça
s'explique dans les années précédentes
mais je pense moins aujourd'hui et sur
la rente du nucléaire moi ce qui m'a
toujours interrogé on voit bien vous
avez exposé les faillites de la filière
nucléaire française sur le triptyque la
sous-traitance la guerre entre arriva et
EDF et puis le fait qu'on est tous misé
sur la rente dans l'export qui a été une
catastrophe puisqu'on n'a pas été
capable et on est lié à des contrats
extrêmement dangereux d'un point de vue
économique et financier
et puis enfin voilà donc c'est c'est
sur la perte compétences nucléaire on
voit bien que c'est peut-être pas les
méchants et écologistes ou idéologues
contre le nucléaire une question une
dernière question sur la sûreté puisque
vous en avez évoqué dans le projet de
loi de relance nucléaire il y a des
choses assez
en tout cas qui peuvent nous interroger
et nous inquiéter sur la sûreté
puisqu'on est là sur un allègement des
normes de sécurité qui pour un certain
nombre de personnes que nous avons
auditionnées disent que c'est à cause de
ces normes de sûreté que nous arrivons
pas à faire fonctionner nos réacteurs
puisqu'on a des normes qui sont plus
importantes sur le prolongement
notamment des centrales alors qu'il y a
un certain nombre de problématiques vous
avez noté l'ASN et qui est visites en
dans les usines de fabrication d'Italie
mais la problématique EDF ne transmet
pas les informations et les défauts de
fabrication alors qu'on voit les énormes
problématiques de sûreté et de dangers
que ça pose aujourd'hui
voilà sur le lobbying nucléaire c'est un
sujet qui est délicat
parce que en fait
le sujet du nucléaire en France était
étroitement lié
à l'organisation même de l'État même si
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que j'avais été
frappé lorsque j'étais au gouvernement
c'était pas nous qui avions les chiffres
mais que c'était EDF et que ça me
paraissait pas normal
le lien étroit entre nucléaire civil et
nucléaire militaire
et le l'importance qui est accordée
au nucléaire dans les politiques
françaises de manière générale
fait que ça dépasse le cas de lobby et
j'ai écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
l'état nucléaire pour essayer
d'expliquer le pourquoi du comment et
montrant notamment comment si on prend
les différents conseils d'administration
par exemple des grands groupes français
et nucléaires on voit qu'il y a des
intérêts qui sont croisés
comment on voit sur le plan politique de
la manière dont les les influences
peuvent jouer enfin il y a énormément de
choses à dire lorsque j'étais lorsque
j'étais ministrement il est clair que
j'étais dans le collimateur mais le jour
de ma nomination donc j'ai eu des coups
bas bon ça fait partie de la vie
ministériel je savais très bien d'où ça
venait
notamment avec un faux débat autour du
code de l'environnement qui de monter de
toutes pièces lorsque comme par comme
par hasard le Conseil d'État rendu sa
décision sur christmasville bon tout ça
je l'ai raconté je dirais qu'il y a
prescription ça fait 25 ans voilà donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même très
très puissant et vous avez raison de
parler des trolls je m'en prends des
paquets heureusement que j'ai le cuir
dur parce que c'est franchement
insupportable c'est insupportable alors
je dise je dis pas des choses
extraordinaires franchement pas le
papier que j'ai fait dans le monde m'a
attiré alors 150 000 vues donc ça
intéressait les gens mais un paquet de
d'immondis
aussi que le sol donc ça c'est quand
même très difficile
d'avoir un débat sur ce sujet dans des
conditions d'hystéries qui ont ce qui
ont cette importance
lorsque
[Musique]
des ancien député ADN de mes
collaboratrice qu'on devrait faire
disparaître tous les avocats qui sont
qui défendent des causes antinucléaires
je m'interroge oui
voilà donc
moi ça j'ai un âge qui fait que je suis
très sereine je suis à l'aise dans mes
baskets je pense que vous l'avez compris
j'estime avoir été toujours très
rigoureuse dans tout ce que j'ai fait et
parfaitement honnête donc j'ai aucun
problème mais c'est franchement pas très
agréable voilà alors même que je pense
que les questions que nous posons que je
pose que vous posez sont des questions
qui méritent d'être posées ensuite il
peut y avoir des réponses différentes
mais de poser la question relatif du
renouvelable et du nucléaire quand on
est à 4 centimes d'un côté 12 centimes
de l'autre et qu'on s'engage pour 60 ans
je pense que c'est des questions qui
méritent d'être mystère la table et de
manière aussi apaisée que possible
c'était sujet rationnels il y a pas de
c'est pas une lutte religieuse le député
le député tout à l'heure m'a dit que
j'avais une religion
du renouvelable non j'ai aucune religion
du renouvelable ça n'a pas de sens c'est
pas des sujets religieux c'est pas une
croyance on croit pas on fait des
analyses et ensuite les analyses
rationnelles amènent à une situation où
à une autre et moi je soutiens
effectivement que la question de la
dépendance puisque c'est le sujet de
votre commission quand même un sujet
excessivement important
alors
je vous ai répondu sur le billet en tant
que ministre j'ai jamais été chez les
républicains en fait j'ai jamais été
dans aucun parti politique sauf qu'à 21
donc voilà donc surtout qu'à l'époque
c'était le RPR
donc j'appartenais au gouvernement j'ai
aucun
j'ai aucun problème avec ça j'y étais
titre de la société civile si vous
voulez lisez le décret de composition du
gouvernement en face de mon nom il y
avait société civile j'étais pas j'avais
pas d'appartenance d'appartenance
politique
ensuite au niveau du Parlement européen
où il c'est des sujets qu'on a bien
entendu aborder le sujet du sujet du
nucléaire je me souviens qu'au moment de
c'était Fukushima François j'avais posé
une question
au commissaire à l'énergie
qui m'avait répondu que je ferais mieux
de m'occuper de la sécurité des
centrales nucléaires en France plutôt
que de poser des questions sur Fukushima
c'est pour vous dire un peu l'ambiance
l'ambiance qui régnait voilà
donc bon ma position elle a été ce que
je lui ai répondu avec beaucoup de
franchise j'ai rien caché
de ce que de ce que de ce que je pensais
au sur la dépendance oui je vous ai
répondu Kazakhstan bekistan le Niger il
y a aussi un peu le Canada soyons
honnêtes tous c'est quand même moins
problématique enfin les autres c'est
quand même très problématique
alors sans suite sur le la rampe
nucléaire la surcapacité moi j'ai
répondu assez longuement monsieur le
rapporteur Armand tout à l'heure sur ce
sujet en expliquant pourquoi si on prend
les choses dans la durée la surcapacité
qui était celle qui existait dans les
années 90 peut-être analyser
différemment quand on a ouvert et
beaucoup exporté enfin à l'époque
c'était pas le cas et c'est quand même
ça qui a entraîné ce problème de
surconsommation de l'électricité en
France avec les problèmes de pointe qui
ont quand même coûté très cher à EDF et
qui qui était le risque majeur que nous
avions cet hiver dans l'hypothèse où il
y avait un hiver froid tout simplement
parce que nous importons beaucoup
d'électricité de chez nos voisins et
quand faut-il encore qu'ils puissent
produire pour nous vendre donc le
problème était celui-là est-ce que il
produiront assez pour nous vendre un
moment ou même vont consommer davantage
même si comme je l'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure nous représente au 50% de la
donc c'est quand même c'est quand même
tout à fait considérable alors ensuite
sur la santé c'est un sujet qui me
histoire de la santé environnementale
est un sujet qui m'intéresse depuis 30
ans donc comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans mon décret de compétence
que vous verrez puisque je voulais
joindre j'avais la santé et
l'environnement ce qui était tout à fait
nouveau venez de s'amener d'être créé et
donc oui j'ai eu à réagir sur l'histoire
de des
surcas de le signalag qui était l'étude
du professeur viel qui a été confirmée
dix ans plus tard par une autre étude
dont j'ai oublié l'auteur qui était une
femme mais qui disait exactement
exactement la même chose alors c'est sur
une partie des enfants c'est une classe
d'âge déterminée je sais plus ce que
c'est 4 en 7 ans un truc comme ça il y a
un contestablement
des problèmes des surcats sur Tchernobyl
bon je vais pas être trop longue je
pourrais vous raconter Tchernobyl que
j'ai vécu parce que tout simplement je
défendais les Hollandais à l'époque et
que je suis arrivée au Pays-Bas où on
m'a accueilli avec des parapluies qui
étaient des véritables en brelles
énormes parasol et quand j'ai rigolé en
disant ben vous avez des parapluies qui
sont comme spéciaux au Pays-Bas ils
m'ont répondu madame on vous protège de
la pluie radioactive et donc je
défendais à l'époque avec Christian
hublot nous défendions la province de la
Hollande et les wateringues sur la
pollution du Rhin et donc on a eu tous
les chiffres
d'augmentation de la radioactivité dans
le rein dans la Meuse enfin tous les
tous les foins sont alliés donc je suis
rentré en France avec tous ces chiffres
qui nous convaincu personne jusqu'à ce
que une femme en l'espèce Corinne
lalleau qui était journaliste à TF1
accepte de faire le journal de 20h en
prenant deux salades en se mettant sur
la frontière je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de ça en disant celle-là on la
mange celle-là on la mange pas il
faudrait peut-être savoir pourquoi
donc j'ai des souvenirs extrêmement
précis de Tchernobyl ce que je peux vous
dire sur la thyroïde bon alors j'étais
le ministre qui a sorti en 96 les
premiers chiffres sur la radioactivité
en France à la suite de Tchernobyl date
de 96 vous pouvez retrouver ça et j'ai
un souvenir très précis qui date de la
même année c'est que nous avions soigné
en France
800 enfants alors je sais plus si
c'était
ukrainien ou biélorus c'est l'un des
deux qui était qui avait des cancers de
la thyroïde
ça c'était très bien sauf que une fois
qu'on les ait soignés ils étaient
reparti chez eux ils avaient pas les
médicaments qu'il fallait et donc
j'avais obtenu des laboratoires français
800 médicaments pour un an pour les
gosses
et c'est un convoi de la Croix Rouge qui
partait de Notre-Dame 96 qui a emmené
ses
800 médicaments pour chacun des enfants
qui avaient été contaminés donc on
reconnaits
encore une fois t'es pas chez nous mais
chez nous on s'est rendu compte de ça
quand même un petit paquet d'années plus
tard et vous avez raison de souligner le
fait que on a un problème sur les études
de santé mais enfin ça dépasse largement
le cadre de la commission
nous sommes allés avec François à
Fukushima City en 2011 en août 2011 où
les maires de famille se plaignaient
exactement de la même chose que ce dont
c'était plein de virus c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'y avait pas d'études
de suivi de la morbidité alors que il y
avait des il y avait des réels problèmes
le dernier point que vous avez abordé si
je n'ai rien oublié c'est la sûreté du
nucléaire et l'allongement des légendes
de sûreté bon c'est évidemment pas une
bonne idée j'ai dit tout à l'heure
monsieur député allemand maintenant m'a
demandé de m'expliquer sur ce point
pourquoi j'étais inquiète en termes de
sûreté j'ai expliqué pourquoi du comment
je pense que c'est vraiment pas au
moment où on a des centrales
vieillissantes qu'il faut réduire les
règles de sûreté en plus il y a quand
même des règles communautaires elles
sont assez larges j'entends bien mais
quand même qui ne sont pas que euratum
c'est des règles et erratum et Union
européenne en ce qui concerne la sûreté
nucléaire et donc s'il y a des
allègements je pense que ça passera pas
comme net à la boîte d'autant plus qu'on
a quand même beaucoup de centrales qui
sont proches de nos voisins il y a chaud
avec la Belgique vous avez quatre noms
vous avez Bugey avec les Suisses donc
tous ces gens là ils regardent quand
même d'assez près ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe chez nous voilà je pense madame
le député avoir répondu aux questions
que vous avez bien voulu me poser
bien merci beaucoup madame Lepage encore
une fois je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser les circonstances un peu
rocambolesques de la fin de notre
audition le problème
et je vous remercie pour le temps que
vous avez consacré à notre commission
d'enquête la rapidité à laquelle je vous
je vous le dois vous avez répondu à
notre application nationale donc c'est
tout à fait normal je vous ai répondu
avec
franchise j'ai prêté serment je vous ai
raconté
en bien ou en mal vous jugerez mais
enfin ce qui est pour moi la vérité et
donc je vous ai remis un certain nombre
de documents
il m'a été demandé de vous l'envoyer sur
une forme numérisée ce que je ferai
demain matin la source un peu tard mais
demain matin je vous le ferai envoyer
sous une forme numérique de manière à ce
que vous les guides de manière plus
aisée parce que je pense que comme c'est
des documents sur lesquels je me suis
appuyé c'est bien que vous puissiez en
disposer même si vous les avez déjà
voilà merci en tout cas de votre
attention